Wir haben Angst vor der Zukunft und wir prangern alles an.
Wenn wir schon über Linux reden.
Ja, wir sind alt. Macht euch das klar. Wie können wir uns verjüngen? Wem müssen wir zuhören?
Ich verstehe diese Frage und ich verstehe auch die folgenden Fragen, die kommen werden.
Wer bringt uns das Licht?
Wer ist der neue Steve?
Wer bringt uns? Wer zieht uns mit? Wer zeigt uns den Weg?
Verstehen Sie bitte, dass ich darauf keine Antwort geben möchte.
Die Angestellten, ey. Spur nicht.
Warum? Am Teil dieser Antworten würde die Bevölkerung verunsichern.
Ich hab Angst.
So, alles klar, Jungs?
Hab da, wie ist der Lebkuchen-Pegel?
Ich hab einen einzigen gegessen, der Rest hat gleich sofort gepasst.
Das ist die Lebkuchen-Ober.
Lebokalypse.
Das ist die Nebo Katnitzer.
Wer war das? Wer hat nach Lebkuchen gestehen?
Es war kein Einzeltäter. Ach so, bei uns meint sie. Also ich gehe stehe, dass ich das war, aber nur die letzten Jahre. Ich glaube dieses Jahr noch nicht.
Glaube ich.
Aber jetzt beschweren wollen, ich meine, es sind doch leckere Lebkuchen.
Ja.
Auch wenn schon Level Gelb erreicht ist bei mir.
Wir schaffen das schon. Es ist ja noch ein bisschen Zeit, bis man die nicht mehr essen kann.
Ja, aber wir müssen im Prinzip schon Einhalt gebieten, weil das reicht ja schon gefühlt bis zum nächsten Weihnachtsevent.
Nächsten komm ich.
Na, hier wir sind's, Freak Show, hallo.
Die alten Männer und die Stimme der Jugend.
Genau, haben wir wieder reingeholt, um wieder den Anschluss zu finden zu den Trends, zu den Ereignissen.
Clemens ist noch müde vom letzten Mal.
Ja, der hat sich auch verausgabt, sehr. War eine gute Sendung. Die letzte fand ich gut, kann man empfehlen. Sollte dir das noch nicht gehört haben, drück dir jetzt mal auf Stopp.
Reicht auch für zwei Tage.
Genau.
Auch bis zum nächsten Weihnachtsfest.
Ja, also wir begrüßen alle Hörer daheim an den Hörgeräten und den Smartphones. Er hat mich gefragt, was heißt Smartphone, eigentlich auf Deutsch korrekt. Also gibt es ja irgendwie kein Wort für.
Gab es früher für sowas wie ein iPad und so, also die ersten PDAs, gab es dann ein deutsches Wort. Was ist das? Personal Digital Assistant.
Wie hieß die Firma nochmal? Die erste wurde jetzt so...
Wobei das irgendwie eine etwas merkwürdige Abkürzung ist für Deutsche. Zumindest für Deutsche, die schon mal Kinder bekommen haben.
Nein.
Wie nein?
Dazu möchte ich mich nicht äußern.
Das ist so hinten in die Wirbelsäule rein, um sozusagen den Schmerz abzuschalten.
Einmal totlegen.
PDA hätte man ganz gut gebrauchen können in den letzten Wochen, wenn man sich so die Nachrichten angeguckt hat. So genau das Richtige gewesen. Aber halt der Digital Assistant nicht. Aber ich glaube, der gemeine Deutsche sagt immer noch Handy, oder?
Oder Mobiltelefon.
Das ist aber auch sehr gemein dann.
Das sagt auch keiner.
Ich schon.
Ernsthaft?
Ich sag nicht Handy.
Ich sag iPhone.
Du sagst nicht Handy.
Mobiltelefon.
Oder nur Foden.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich sage.
Wer ruft denn jetzt an?
Ja, Menschen, die...
Ich sehe es auf deiner Uhr, dass dich jemand anruft.
Ja, Menschen, von denen ich schon lange wollte, dass sie mich mal anrufen und dann rufen sie in solchen Momenten an. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen dramatisch.
So ist es. Freak Show geht vor.
Ja, so sieht es nämlich aus.
Das wär dein Millionengewinn gewesen.
Genau. Also das geübte Ohr ist natürlich hier schon voll synchronisiert, aber um die Sache dann auch mal deutlich zu machen, also Dennis ist in der Runde.
Ja, für den Weltfrieden.
Wie lange ginnst du eigentlich noch als Stimme der Jugend?
Ja, läuft aus jetzt. Langsam. Also für Stimme der Jugend nennt man sich ja auch wie Hacker nicht selber, sondern wird man genannt. Und wenn das irgendwann abäppt, dann ist das halt so.
Stimmt, dann ist man raus.
Dann ist man raus.
Roddy, du gehst auch nicht mehr durch als Stimme der Jugend.
Ich glaub nicht, nein.
Ja, vielleicht müssen wir uns verjüngen.
Hast du geschaut jetzt gerade, oder was?
Man könnte, ja, wie könnten wir uns denn verjüngen? Wir könnten natürlich mal in so einem Jungbrunnen baden. Oder so.
Das geht schief.
Naja, also, ich weiß nicht, ob der Deutsche noch Handy sagt. Die Deutschen, die Deutsche. Oder, wenn sie das nicht sagen, sagen sie, glaube ich, schon eher auch Smartphone.
Doch.
Das wird gesagt.
Nee, finde ich nicht.
Das ist auch in den Medien. Weil die haben schon verstanden, dass das jetzt da ist. Weil es ist jetzt da.
Wir haben alle ein Smartphone, dann sagt man das so nicht mehr, weil man geht eh davon aus, dass es eins ist.
Also ich hab ja so, naja, wie soll ich sagen, wir machen in der Firma so User-Tests, wo wir so Leute von der Straße ranholen. Und dann dürfen die irgendwie...
100 Leute haben wir gefragt.
Dann dürfen die über die Software einmal drüber gucken und Dinge tun. Und da war heute eine da, die penetrant immer nur von ihrem Smartphone sprach. Und zwar so penetrant, dass bis zum Schluss nicht klar war, ist es jetzt ein Android oder ein iPhone? Also es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die sagen penetrant Smartphone. Die gibt es.
Ja, ich glaube, um ehrlich zu sein, ich sage entweder iPhone oder ich sage Smartphone. Also Smartphone sage ich halt, wenn alle gemeint sind.
Smartphone sage ich, wenn ich politisch korrekt sein will, ich jemanden kennenlerne oder zum ersten Mal mit jemandem zu tun habe und dann frage, ob nicht die auf ihrem Gerät mal da schnell was nachgucken könnten oder so. Also hast du nicht einen. Und dann will man halt nicht so unfreundlich sein. Unfreundlich sein und so, wie sagt man denn, Assumptious, also so hier so vor eingenommen, wie auch immer. Und dann sagt man politisch korrekterweise Smartphone.
Ich glaube, das erste Kästchen ist jetzt hier schon gecheckt, ne?
Welches denn?
Das Denglisch.
Denglisch? Haben wir ein Denglisch-Kästchen?
Gibt's auf jeden Fall, ich find's gibt's grad nicht.
Also ich hab hier keins.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir ja mal gleich hier einführen und uns auch bedanken. Also es gab ja schon zur letzten Sendung, gab's ja schon so erste Bingo-Karten-Online-Versuche.
Das hab ich mitgenommen, auch in Abwesenheit, ja.
Aber was jetzt diese Woche hier eintrudelte, das sprengt ja alle Vorstellungen, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Ach doch, da ist Denglisch, ja, tatsächlich. Klick.
Ihr dürft gar nicht mitspielen.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Angestellte sind von dem sowieso ausgeschlossen, so wie es heißt, ihr wisst schon.
Mitarbeiter und Angehörige.
Mitarbeiter und ihre Angehörige sind von dem Preisausschreiben schubdiwupp ausgeschlossen.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe und jetzt nicht komplett, ja doch, genau. Also das ganze kommt von Timo. mosushi.net/bingounddas ist einfach mal, das finde ich jetzt mal echt beeindruckend. Das ist korrekt. Da hört jemand zu und macht sich Gedanken und kann auch noch was. Also das Ganze ist eine Online-Bingo-Karte in der zuletzt von uns bevorzugten 7x7-Variante.
Ach, das habt ihr bevorzugt? Wieso das denn?
Na, wir hatten glaube ich ansatzweise drüber gesprochen, weil so die ersten Varianten, diese Rupoppen, waren so 5x5 und 25 Sachen. Jetzt gibt es ein bisschen wenig, genau, das dachten wir uns nämlich auch. Und jetzt gibt es hier die 7x7-Variante.
Also ich glaube, es fing alles damit an, dass jemand im Chat immer Prost geschrieben hat, wenn du wie auch immer gesagt hast.
Das ist die Trinkspiele, das ist aber was anderes. Naja, aber Torcheck hier irgendwie mit hübscher Vektor-Grafik in der Brose und ja, auch schon so einem Ansatz von so einem, wie soll ich sagen, also das Ganze ist jetzt sozusagen nicht nur so eine Karte, die man sich vielleicht ausdrückt, sondern das Ganze hat eben auch noch so ein bisschen Spielcharakter, in dem man hier rumklicken kann. Wobei sich mir ehrlich gesagt in der kurzen Zeit, die ich jetzt leider nur hatte, mir das anzuschauen, mir das jetzt noch nicht so hundertprozentig erschlossen hat, inwiefern Game Control hier auch schon so vollständig integriert ist. Hast du da schon ein bisschen Einblick gewonnen, Rudi?
Also wenn ich den Text, den ich auch nur so leicht überflogen hab, richtig interpretiert hab, kannst du zwar auf die Kästchen draufklicken und dann werden sie grün, aber wenn du dann eins dieser Gewinnbildchen, Gewinnmuster, so heißen sie, tatsächlich zusammen hast, dann musst du irgendwie noch selber aktiv werden und einen Screenshot posten.
Dieser Text da drunter, der ist ja länger als die Apple Store-AGBs, also das ist auch nicht so schwer, nicht so leicht zu überblicken.
Also hier steht, gebastelt wird an und einer der Punkte ist Gewinnerkennung.
Ja.
Ansonsten kann man sich ja bei GitHub beteiligen und Patches schicken.
Ja, also, okay, wir erkennen an, das ist sozusagen Work in Progress, aber es ist definitiv Work, wo man sich vielleicht mal mit einbringen sollte, denn ich überleg gerade, was man jetzt eigentlich machen will. Das eine Problem ist ja, beim normalen Bingo sind es doch nur Zahlen, oder? Da ist ja dann immer klar, welche Zahlen schon gezogen worden sind und dann liegen die aus. Also es ist sozusagen, es gibt auf der Webseite, also jetzt mal gleich hier übertragen auf das Spielsystem hier, also es müsste im Prinzip auf der Webseite mehr oder weniger registriert werden, was denn jetzt tatsächlich auch gefallen ist.
Naja, aber Teil vom Bingo ist ja, dass du selber die Kreuzchen machst.
Aber wer überprüft das denn?
Aber trotzdem muss ja sozusagen die Information, dass das auch tatsächlich hat, angekreuzt werden können.
Genau, wir brauchen die offizielle Bingo-Auflösung am Ende der Sendung in den Show Notes, wo die offizielle Lösung da ist und dann jeder auch gucken kann.
Ja, eigentlich müsste man das Audio mitschneiden und dann eben auch den Beleg kiefern.
Aber jeder hat auch eine andere Karte, es gibt keine offizielle Auflösung.
Ja, aber wir markieren alles, was gesagt wurde, dann kannst du das sozusagen bei dir auch abkreuzen.
Ja, aber wir können das ja nicht machen.
Aber jemand muss halt festhalten, was gesagt wurde.
Ja, und wo und wann?
Ja, aber der Trick ist doch auch, dass man ja natürlich die Sendung hören muss und aufpassen muss, weil wenn du halt nicht aufpasst, kannst du dich ankreuzen.
Aber ich sag mal so, Show Notes war gestern. Bingo-Karte ist jetzt the future. Also, nur postest jetzt mal nicht irgendwie mehr die Show Notes, sondern auch die Kapitelmarken sind eigentlich nur noch so Icons, wo man in jeder Sendung zu Dinglish, zu Apple, was auch immer springen kann.
Es gibt gar kein Show Notes-Feld.
Ja, also da ist sicherlich noch einiges zu holen. Ich würde auch sagen, wenn man sich die Liste der nicht verwendeten Buzzwords anschaut, da ist ja sozusagen aber das ist ja der Overflow. Wenn du Mission klickst, dann werden die ja gut, aber das heißt ja, dass du quasi 10, also wenn du alle 49 Felder belegt hast, dann hast du 10 nicht, also eigentlich müsste ja der Bestand noch ausgebaut werden. Das heißt, da sind wir dann gefragt, wir müssen sozusagen weitere Buzzwords liefern.
Übrigens, wir haben das nächste Bingo-Feld. Hast du nicht aufgepasst, ne? Tim gewinnt schon mal nicht. Ja, für die Hörer jetzt da draußen, die Mitbingo und Kapitelmarken haben wir gerade erwähnt, das ist wiederum diese deutsche Balder links da auf deiner Kamera.
Ah, der so weint. Der deutsche Balder. Dazu muss man sagen, also diese Bilder sind wirklich großartig. Viele von denen zumindest.
Ich bin gespannt. Irgendwie müsste sich halt eine Präsenz geben, wo quasi alle Buzzwords sind und dann aufleuchten, wenn sie confirmed sind, dass sie irgendwann stattgefunden haben. Und natürlich müssten Leute sich auch vor der Sendung quasi mit ihrer Bingo-Karte registrieren und dürfen sie natürlich während der Sendung auch nicht mehr ändern. Da ist halt so ein bisschen Glück dabei. Weil man hat ja...
Vielleicht übertreibst du es. Aber auch nur vielleicht.
Das Bingo-OS wird jetzt gerade hier designed.
Bingo-OS?
Na gut, ich meine, das lässt sich ja dann im Prinzip auf alle Live-Sendungen übertragen. Du hast halt sozusagen ein Set von Buzzwords. Du hast halt deinen Game-Server. Du meldest dich halt an. Ich denke das jetzt einfach nur durch, wie das für meinen Geschmack laufen könnte. Du machst ja deinen Account und sagst, okay, generiere mir eine Karte. Dann kriegst du eine Karte zugeteilt. Die ändert sich dann halt auch nicht mehr. Die gilt dann ab dem Moment. Und dann musst du selber immer noch die Felder anklicken. Also wenn du es überhört hast, dann hast du halt Pech gehabt. Aber wenn du eins anklickst, dann muss es natürlich auch gefallen sein. Die Frage ist, ob du in dem Moment sofort eine Fehlermeldung bekommst. Oder nur, wenn du dann irgendwie behauptest, du hättest Bingo, dass das dann überprüft wird.
Dass dann jemand nochmal 5 Stunden Podcast durchhören muss, um zu überprüfen.
Man könnte ja sonst einfach auf alles draufklicken und sagen...
Und wir wollen ja so eine Live-Anzeige, wann wer so ein Ding klickt und wie viele. Damit wir mal sehen, das haben wir gerade gesagt.
Genau, eigentlich bräuchte man so ein Master, so ein Showview für uns, wo wir dann schon mal sehen können, ah, es wurde sozusagen wohl was gesagt und so und so viele haben auch das geklickt. Da geht noch einiges, da ist was zu wollen.
Der Elthmosen denkt sich jetzt, was habe ich getan? Tim hat jetzt volle Fahrt aufgenommen mit Features, Features, Features und ich wollte doch nur eine halbwegs dynamische Pingu-Card.
Wir haben ja ja auch genug Preise verflossen können. Wir haben ja noch so ein paar Küchenwagen über und Lebkuchen und was nicht alles. Also da geht noch was.
Also nicht Bing OS, sondern Bingo OS.
Und es muss natürlich in die Podcast-Klienz dann auch integriert werden.
Genau das Podlove-Bingo-Format.
Du willst doch nur unseren Lieblings-Podcast-Klein-Programmierer trollen.
Tja, naja, also ich kann ja nur sagen, ihr wollt es doch auch. Na gut, auf jeden Fall, Timo, ich hoffe, du weißt, worauf du dich eingelassen hast, aber du schreibst ja auch, du brauchst jetzt mal wieder etwas Programmierbetätigung. Hier ist auf jeden Fall eine Menge zu holen.
Da musst du nur mal kurz Tim von der Seite.
Naja, also wenn man das halt so, dann eben so generisch macht, das, was weiß ich, es könnte ja im Prinzip jeder Podcast dann irgendwann auch so seine eigenen, naja, also wenn man sich sozusagen anmeldet und sagt, ich bin jetzt ein Podcast und ich will irgendwie bingo-tauglich sein, dann legt man das an und dann können dann die Hörer selber Grafiken hochladen und Basswörter anmelden, dass man so ein Admin-Interface hat, dass so alles zusammengetragen wird. Dann noch eine iOS-App dazu und dann kann man das auch monetarisieren.
Noch Dollar Dollar.
Gut, dass wir keine anderen Themen haben.
Ich bin jetzt schon irgendwie vorsichtig, Dinge zu sagen, die auf diesen Feldern stehen. Aber mein Bier ist alle.
Das darf man jetzt nicht einfach so sagen.
Ja, es ist aber trotzdem alle und ich hole mir jetzt noch einen.
Ich mache das mal weg, nicht dass wir jetzt die ganze Zeit darauf starren.
Ich habe jetzt selber eins.
Ach du spielst jetzt selber mit?
Nee, nur zum Spaß.
Nur so zum Gucken, wie viel es dir anfühlt.
Ich sage jetzt, wenn ich so eine kleine Themenlücke habe, werde ich einfach alle Bingo-Words hintereinander sagen.
Das gilt aber nicht. Ich weiß. Das funktioniert so auch nicht. Ja, sonst noch was passiert? Ich muss zugeben, heute war leider ein etwas überladener Tag. Und ich habe nicht so richtig das Feedback analysiert. Das tut mir natürlich sehr leid. Da war auch wieder so einiges. In letzter Zeit hagelt es ja geradezu Kommentare. Die Sendung war ein bisschen lang, wurde angemerkt.
Das stimmt.
Aber wie ich schon angemerkt hatte, dass...
Die Leute wollten das so.
Ja, wir wollten das vor allem auch so. Also ich hatte vor allem auch den Eindruck, Clemens wollte das in etwa so. Ja, Probleme habe ich nur nach wie vor mit meinem Download-Server. Das habe ich irgendwie noch nicht so richtig klären können, was da eigentlich das Problem ist.
Dass du immer noch in der Wolke bist?
Ja, vielleicht ist das das Problem. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe mir vorgenommen, wenn ich jetzt die Sendung release, dass ich da noch mal ein bisschen mitmonitore und schaue, was da tatsächlich abgeht, ob da irgendwelche Systemparameter sich unglücklich verhalten. Müssen wir dann sehen.
Und geknistert hat es auch wieder in der Mitteebene, habe ich gehört.
Was? Achso, nee, nicht in der Mitteebene. Ich habe eine Sendung unterwegs aufgenommen und habe eine Beta-Version einer Software verwendet, die leider an einer Stelle falsch konfiguriert war. Die da einen falschen Parameter einspielte. Ich bin unschuldig. Und dann waren Buffergrößen zu klein und dann wird's blöde. Also absolut vermeidbar gewesen, aber in dem Moment, ja, habe ich leider nicht genug Geistesgegenwart besessen, das ernst genug zu nehmen. Aber ich dachte, das wäre nur auf einen Kanal beschränkt gewesen und dann war es halt irgendwie anders. So sieht's aus.
Ja, war letztes Mal so lang jetzt schon gut.
Ich bin auch schon ganz schön...
Kommen wir eigentlich alle auf den Kongress, ja? Also wir alle kommen alle auf den Kongress, oder? Roddy?
Warst du vor letztes Mal auch da, oder?
Ein Mann mit Constraints.
Also, wie sind da unsere Pläne eigentlich? Haben wir welche?
Na, wenn Roddy nicht da ist und Clemens auch nicht da, dann haben wir keine Pläne.
Also ich warte jetzt gerade noch auf die finale Absegnung unseres Sendezentrum-Konzepts. Ich bin da eigentlich ganz zuversichtlich, aber... Wie das immer so ist, der Kongress rollt ja dann auch immer erst auf den letzten Metern so richtig an, kommt in so einen Orga-Modus, und dann muss man auf einmal alles mal ganz schnell gehen. Aber wenn es so stattfindet, wie wir uns das so vorstellen, dann haben wir da auf jeden Fall eine Bühne und auch eine Schicke, und dann müsste da eigentlich was gehen. Dementsprechend wird auf jeden Fall nicht da sein, die Frage, ob wir dann trotzdem irgendwas reißen. Können uns ja einfallen lassen.
Na, wenn Roddy auch nicht da ist, wird es ja ein bisschen dünn.
Dann wird es ein bisschen öde. Ohne Roddy machst du natürlich keinen Spaß.
Müssen wir dich einfliegen lassen, Roddy?
Fliegen bis nach Hamburg, das lohnt sich ja nun wirklich nicht.
Na, wenn du zum Abend erst wieder zu Hause sein willst.
Besonders, wenn der ICE auch irgendwie da an der Jungverneide hält.
Dammtor.
Dammtor war es, ja.
Du kannst morgens hinfahren, machen Sendung, fährst wieder zurück, wirst du zum Essen wieder zu Hause.
Wir machen morgens eine Sendung?
Nee, morgens fährt er los. Dann machen wir die Sendung, dann fährt er zurück und ist zum Essen wieder zu Hause.
Es gab ja das Gerücht, dass es kein GSM-Netzwerk geben wird auf dem Kongress.
Ja, es wurde aber schon...
Also, Gerücht ist gut gesagt.
Es war erst ein Fakt und dann wieder ein... Eine Fehlmeldung.
Es war keine Fehlmeldung, sondern es war halt so, dass die... Wir haben das ja sicherlich hier schon häufiger erwähnt, dass es halt immer so ein GSM-Netzwerk gibt und dazu wurden halt Requenzen benutzt, die noch, glaube ich, zu diesen alten Deckbändern gehörten, die mal eingestellt wurden. Und da konnte man dann irgendwie drauf rumfunken, weil die halt sonst keinem gehörten. Und das hat sich aber jetzt geändert. Das heißt, die Rec-TP... Oder Bundesnetzagentur? Ich weiß grad nicht. Auf jeden Fall wurde dieser Frequenzbereich Vodafone zugeteilt. Und...
Verkauft.
Verkauft, genau. Weil man kann ja nicht genug haben. Keine Ahnung, was wir da fahren wollen. Wahrscheinlich LTE.
Warum eigentlich Vodafone? Gibt's die überhaupt noch?
Ja, sicher.
Kennst du irgendjemand, der bei Vodafone ist?
Ich nicht. Vodafone ist jetzt der eine, andere große Player. Die haben sich auch Kabel Deutschland gekauft.
Mein Freundeskreis teilt sich eigentlich in Telekom und O2 auf. Und dann gibt's Leute, die haben Vodafone. Und das sind komischerweise auch die Leute, die Windows-Phones haben. Was genau die andere Aufteilung ist.
Windows-Vodafone.
Also ich hab, glaube ich, sehr lange allmöglichen Leuten davon abgeraten, zum Vodafone zu gehen, wie ich es auch gerne nenne, weil deren Service, also da jemals aus dem Vertrag rauszukommen und so, das ist einfach, also es war zumindest lange Zeit einfach die Hölle auf Erden. Die haben sich dann im Service so quergestellt, irgendwie eine kundenfreundliche Entscheidung zu treffen oder zu teilen, da musste man immer mit Händen und Füßen kämpfen. Und irgendwie hatten da so zwei, drei Freunde so richtig, Storys aus der Hölle zu berichten, dann hab ich irgendwie allen anderen dann immer die Kunden weitergetragen, Finger weg von Vodafone. Aber vielleicht hat sich das mittlerweile auch geändert, vielleicht sind die mittlerweile viel besser als O2 sogar. Weiß es nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht. Also ich fand das nie so attraktiv und Vodafone und Telekom hatten ja auch ohnehin nie so richtig die Datentarife, die man haben will.
Ihr sagt, einer chats sogar gleich, genau den Vertragshessel hab ich gerade.
Mir war Vodafone nie sympathisch. Die haben eigentlich immer alles falsch gemacht.
Die sind auch die Einzigen, die das iPhone locken.
Ja, genau. Immer noch?
Haben sie es erst abgeschafft, jetzt haben sie es wieder eingeführt zum neuen Sechser. Wahrscheinlich wieder nur so kurzfristig für eine Weile bis Anfang des Jahres oder so. Dann heben sie es auch wieder auf, aber die probieren es halt oder machen es halt.
Vodafone schmeckt noch viel mehr so nach dieser Art Provider, die man eigentlich generell so gerne hassen möchte.
Du meinst so Lulu, wie du immer sagst.
Die riechen nach Lulu.
Die riechen nach Lulu, das fehlt auch noch im Bingo.
Lulu-Phone.
Ja, aber die haben natürlich auch, weil sie anfangs da eben deutlich mehr investiert haben, eine bessere Landabdeckung und von daher für Business-Leute und Leute auf dem Land sind halt Telekom und Wodafone oft die einzigen Optionen. Und ich hab keine Ahnung, ob es Regionen gibt, wo O2 mittlerweile nennenswert nachgezogen hat. Auch wenn mein Eindruck ist, dass sich durch diese ganze LTE-Geschichte sich diese Unterschiede langsam auflösen.
Also ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, ich bin ja jetzt von O2 nach Telekom gewechselt und hab das Gefühl, dass die Netzabdeckung schlechter geworden ist. Really?
In Berlin?
Ja. Aber vielleicht ist das auch nur so ein Eindruck von mir. Ich hab da jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, in den letzten Wochen so oft Edge irgendwo gehabt, wie ich es irgendwie schon gar nicht mehr kannte. Also es ist irgendwie ganz merkwürdig.
Warum bist du da gewechselt?
Weil es die Firma bezahlt. Keine Ahnung, woran es liegt. Also vielleicht ist mein Eindruck auch falsch, weil ich vielleicht doch so hohe Erwartungen an die tolle Telekom hab.
Ich hab hier kein Netz. Ich bin in Edge-Land. Das müsste auch nochmal vertont werden.
Also eigentlich seitdem O2 hier auf LTE umgeschaltet, bin ich ganz happy.
Ja, das ist, ja, die haben sich ja...
Und ich hab sogar Voice-Off. LTE hat dann natürlich nicht mehr okay. Ne? Mit der Telekom.
Telefonier auch nicht mehr. Brauchst du das nur für Internet?
Ja, ich eigentlich auch, aber...
Aber wieso? Telekom hat doch auch Voice-Over LTE.
Wie? Ne.
Haben sie kurz gemacht, ging irgendwie nicht, haben sie wieder abgeschaltet und seitdem nicht wieder eingeschaltet.
Oh sorry, ich wollte gerade sagen, noch keine Intervention von Clemens über iMessage. Also, scheinbar noch korrekt zu sein. Clemens hört nämlich aus der Ferne zu und...
Na, ich glaub, er hat vorhin in die Tischkante gewissen und kriegt es jetzt nicht mehr raus.
Gute Strategie. Das geht gar nicht mehr raus jetzt.
Nee, aber was ich mich frage irgendwie, mit iOS 7 ging bei mir kein Visual-Voice-Mail mehr. Und da dachte ich, naja gut, das ist vielleicht O2. Aber die Telekom als Haus- und Hofprovider von Apple sollte es doch vielleicht noch hinkriegen. Aber ich hab irgendwie immer noch kein Visual-Voice-Mail.
Vielleicht sind deine Settings, die du übernommen hast, irgendwie...
Ja, das hab ich aber auch jedes Mal, wenn du ein neues Telefon hast, dann muss ich das erst irgendwie einmal sinken, dann musst du irgendwie was machen oder irgendwie so und dann geht's wieder.
Musst du das für das Device freischalten lassen, das kannst du wahrscheinlich in diesen Shops tun.
Also bei mir muss ich mal sagen, ist schon immer, bei der Telekom die Visual-Voice-Mail an.
Bei mir ist doch keine an.
Ja, bei mir ist das auch hinkommen und gehen.
Also das muss ich sagen, das haben sie bisher immer hinbekommen. Die Visual-Voice-Mail, die war immer an.
Tischkante kommt hin, meint er.
Tippen kann er noch.
Clemens sagt, die Telekom hatte noch nie Voice-of-LTE, dass nur dieses Profil, was sie da raussenden, da stand mal drin, dass es gehen würde, was aber nicht der Fall war. Und dann haben sie es zurückgezogen, so rum war es.
Na gut, dass wir unseren Telefonjoker haben.
Die sind doch nicht so richtig auf Stimmung, ne?
Das ist ja auch Winterschlaf.
Schon, du nicht.
Seit es kalt geworden ist, bin ich auch in so einem totalen Sleepy-State. Ich hatte jetzt echt so zweimal...
Winterschlaf.
Ja, so Hibernation, ne? Als es kalt und jetzt so richtig dunkel wurde. Und dann habe ich heute zu einem Kollegen gesagt, ja, seit einer Woche bin ich in diesem Mami, ich will nicht zur Schule-Modus, wenn ich aufwache. Und er meinte, ja, genau so war es bei mir auch schon die ganze Woche. Irgendetwas liegt in der Luft.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, retten wir uns erstmal mit einfachen Themen.
Neben des einfachen Mannes?
Genau, dem naheliegenden Tess und Hucke. Du hast geschrieben, du hättest einen iPad Pro in der Hand gehabt.
Genau, bei Wuga hat nämlich unser IT-Chefchen, ich hoffe, das ist ziemlich zu nahe, hat vor Wochen einen iPad Pro bestellt mit iPad.
Das heißt Pencil.
Wie auch immer Pencil. Dann wurde das gestern durch die ganze Firma gereicht, damit alle Teams mal gucken können, ob ihr Spiel läuft auf dem iPad Pro, wie das so aussieht und wie sich das anfühlt. Dann war auch das Cover mit der Tastatur. Ist das sowieso dabei? Auf jeden Fall war auch das Cover mit der Tastatur dabei. Also wirklich einmal alles. Und dann die erste Reaktion von allen, die das das erste Mal in die Hand nahmen, war holy shit, das ist groß. Das ist wirklich, das ist nochmal eine andere Kategorie. Das ist wirklich riesig im Vergleich zu so einem normalen iPad. Also ich wüsste gar nicht, es entspricht das irgendeinem, also es ist nicht A3, es ist auch nicht A4, es ist irgendwo dazwischen gefühlt. Also es ist schon, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist nicht so 13 Zoll, ne?
Ja genau, es ist halt schon ein ordentliches Brett. Und es ist ziemlich dünn, also war ich auch so ein bisschen überrascht, dass das so schön flach ist. Und ansonsten, ja was soll man dazu sagen? Also die Tastatur, die ist ja so schön mit so Hub, so ein bisschen, ne? Also man hat ein bisschen Hub, der fühlt sich sehr plastemäßig an, aber man kann relativ gut tippen. Also die Tastatur fühlt sich normal groß an, keine Abstriche sozusagen in der Hinsicht. Und dann haben natürlich alle den Pencil probiert. Und da dachte ich mir jetzt auch, okay, jetzt wollen wir mal sehen, ob da wirklich kein Lag sozusagen ist, und ob das jetzt wirklich so schön wie in den Videos ist. Und bei der mitgelieferten Notes-App, da war das auch gefühlt so. Die Notes-App, die kann ja ziemlich viel. Also ich weiß nicht, ob sie das für das iPad Pro jetzt wirklich so gemacht haben. Da gibt es ja auch irgendwie Overlay-Liniale und allen möglichen Krempel. Und mit dem Stift funktionierte das auf jeden Fall schon mal ziemlich gut. Also auch mit so Schrägstellen und Schrafieren und andere Stifte und so weiter. Das hat sich alles ganz gut angefühlt. Und dann, wenn du dann aber so eine richtige Illustrations-App aufmachst, wie Sketch von Adobe, dann war es doch wieder ein bisschen laggy und so. Aber letztendlich, man muss sagen, der Stift fühlt sich schon, abgesehen vom Lag, ziemlich, ziemlich gut an. Also ich würde sagen, sehr nah an der Wacom Experience, wenn nicht sogar ebenbürtig. In der Hinsicht so, dass die Stiftstellung berücksichtigt wird, Druck und alles Mögliche. Also das war schon ziemlich überzeugend.
Also ich war gestern auch noch mal ganz kurz im Apple Store, hatte ich gerade so ein paar Minuten, aber auch nur so 10 Minuten, die ich da mitgebracht habe.
Was man halt so macht, wenn man mal auf dem Bus wartet, geht man schnell rein.
Genau. Eigentlich wollte ich ja auch noch nebenan bei Tesla anklopfen, dann hatte ich schon keine Zeit mehr, muss hier irgendwie weiterlaufen. Auf jeden Fall...
Nicht so schnell, ich komme im Klick nicht hinterher.
Kann ich erstmal alles bestätigen, soweit du das sagst, wobei ich mir bei diesem Stift noch nicht so hundertprozentig sicher bin. Also es macht so den Eindruck, als ob sie die Hardware auf jeden Fall hinbekommen haben. Der ist relativ lang, man kann ihn auch mit großen Händen problemlos halten, er hat Gewicht, aber er ist nicht zu schwer oder so.
Was er aber nicht ist, im Vergleich zum Beispiel zu den, ich finde ihn nicht besonders ergonomisch, ich glaube die Vakuum-Schliffe die haben ja alle so ein bisschen so, dass die halt so gefällig über dem Finger liegen, damit du da lange mit rumhantelst. Ich meine der Pencil, der ist halt einfach nur glatt und gerade. Pencil gibt es auch solche, wenn man mal zum Modulor geht und die Pencil-Abteilung durchforstet, dann wird man auch feststellen, dass Pencil nicht gleich Pencil ist, aber ja, das war eigentlich so noch was mir dann so aufgefallen ist. So irgendwie, ja weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt damit wirklich länger arbeiten wollen würde, weil dann bestimmt irgendwann so rutschig wird oder keine Ahnung.
Wenn man schwitzige Hände hat, dann wird's schwierig. Ja, aber das sind bestimmt nur so Randparameter. Also was mich, also ich würde wirklich, wirklich, also wenn ich jetzt für mein iPad Mini da die Option hätte mit diesem Stift, ich glaube, die würde ich sofort ziehen. ähm so was scribbeln zu können und auch mal ein paar handschriftliche Notizen zu machen oder auch einfach nur irgendwelche Kästchen und Linien und so weiter zu malen, das ist schon etwas, was man eigentlich mit solchen Dingern machen können möchte. So, ist natürlich dann die Frage, wo steckst du diesen Stift hin, wenn du irgendwie unterwegs bist und so. Dann müssen wir auf jeden Fall nochmal ein paar Antworten liefern. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt bei diesem iPad Pro einfach nicht so das Thema, weil das Ding bewegst du eh nicht. Also, damit rennst du nicht durch die Gegend. Der ist ja so unfassbar groß, dieses Teil. Also, das ist ja eigentlich ein Desktop Tablet, kann man sagen.
Das würde sich auch, ich habe natürlich auch schon auch Spaß gesagt, so, manche Leute, die machen ja ihr iPad Mini ohne Schmerz auch so an den Oberarmen oder so was. Über ihre Fablets, diese großen, wenn du das hier machst, dann hast du hier wirklich einen riesen Segel am Arm.
Da ist der Workout gesichert.
Mit dem iPad Pro irgendwie joggen gehen, wow. Da kannst du es vielleicht ganz gut refinanzieren, kannst ja sozusagen auf dem Rücken dann anschnallen und noch Werbung einblenden. Auf jeden Fall, ich habe mir, ich habe mich voll darauf konzentriert, auf das Schreiben wie mit einem Bleistift. Weil das ist ja für mich ja so ein bisschen das Versprechen, was in diesem Produktnamen auch drin steckt. Dass das Ding im Prinzip funktionieren könnte wie ein Bleistift. Und was mein Gefühl war, die Hardware ist okay, aber die Software braucht einfach noch mehr Optimierung. Also diese Notes App ist halt sehr basic und diese anderen Apps, die ich jetzt ausprobiert habe, waren so zwei, drei da installiert.
Aber die Notes App hast du, also ich fand das ja, ich hab das vorhin noch gar nicht gesehen, dass man dann diese Lineale auch drüber hat und so weiter, das kannte ich ja gar nicht. Gibt's das auch in der normalen Notes App für so Touch?
Das ist ja die normale Notes App.
Okay, ich hab das nämlich noch nie entdeckt, dieses Feature vorher.
Doch, das ist ganz schick, vor allen Dingen mit diesem komischen Lineal, das fand ich irgendwie sehr strange.
Nee, aber okay, gut, das war für mich nur neu, weil ich diese Notes App einfach generell sehr selten benutze.
Ja, kann ich verstehen. Worauf wollte ich jetzt hinaus? Ah ja, genau. Und dann hab ich halt damit geschrieben und mir vorgestellt, jetzt hätte ich halt wirklich einen Bleistift in der Hand gehabt. Was halt nicht ausreichend war, also das ist ja schon so drucksensitiv, aber was ich auch erwarte ist, dass das, was ich male, auch genauso aussieht, wie etwas, was ich mit einem Bleistift male. So, und ich hab halt etwas mehr Druck gemacht und du malst halt immer noch so gräuliche Flächen. Also vielleicht müsste man halt auch sagen können, was für ein Bleistift man jetzt hat. Hab ich jetzt ein 2H, ein 1H, ein HB? Was?
Ja, müsste man vielleicht.
Aber ich mein, das Produkt kam ja gerade erst raus, vielleicht kommt das ja alles noch.
Die Pencil-App.
Also was Bleistifte betrifft, bin ich nerd. Weil das ist schon, ich weiß nicht, hattet ihr früher nicht mehrere Bleistifte?
Ich bin ja nerd, deswegen hab ich keine.
Meistens schon, aber gefunden habe ich dann trotzdem keinen von denen.
Also ich hab mir von Farber, Castel oder wie sie heißen, dann hab ich mir mal so ein kleines Blechset von...
Mit verschiedenen Härten.
Ich hatte eigentlich immer nur Druckbleistifte.
Die haben mich gedacht.
Ich weiß nicht mal ganz genau, was ich hatte, aber ich hatte auf jeden Fall ein 2H, immer ein HB, und was gibt's da noch? 2B oder so? Also die B wird ja dann immer weicher.
Ich weiß, welche ich hatte. Die, die es bei der BVG umsonst gab vor 30 Jahren. Kannst du dich erinnern? Die kurzen.
Vor 30 Jahren?
Ja, oder 40.
Ach, da hat IKEA das her.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das ist das, was ich sozusagen von so einer Software erwarte, dass ich halt verschiedene Stiftvarianten auswählen kann. Keine Ahnung, ob es in den USA so eine Unterscheidung gibt zwischen verschiedenen, weiß nicht, haben die sowas, oder ist das wieder so eine deutsche Sache?
Nee, haben die bestimmt.
Dass sie hier Bleistifte in sechs verschiedenen, gibt's auch bestimmt alles.
Ich glaub, eine deutsche Sache ist, dass es Schreibwarenladen gibt. Also ich glaube, da suchst du dich in Amiland tot, einen Laden zu finden, der nur Stifte verkauft und Papier.
Echt? Da gibt's bestimmt auch Office-Supplies oder so.
Ja, Office-Supplies, aber Schreibwarenladen.
Na da hast du halt so Staples, da kriegst du halt dann irgendwie alles. Stimmt, mit Computer und...
Nee, ich glaub, die haben auch unterschiedliche, weiche Bleistifte.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, ich hab dann mit diesem Ding gemalt und war einfach enttäuscht, dass sich das einfach, wenn man da so ausgefüllt hat, also da war einfach so diese Komplexität des Gezeichneten, wurde einfach dem, wie man das von einem Bleistift erwarten würde, einfach nicht gerecht. Also da ist einfach noch zu wenig Logik in dieser Software. Das ist ja jetzt keine Hardware, in dieser Software, das war einfach nicht bleistiftig genug. Also da braucht man wirklich mal so eine... Bleistiftig. Bleistift.app. Ja, also wo wirklich das Grafitt einfach mal mit so einem Physicall-Model berechnet wird, während du halt malst. Das ist natürlich extrem aufwendig, aber...
Und wenn du das iPad hochnimmst, dann rieselt langsam der Staub von dem, was nicht auf dem Papier geblieben ist.
Wenn ich mit dem Finger drüber wische, dann muss es natürlich auch noch so ein bisschen vermatschen. Und wenn ich mit einem nassen Finger mache, dann mehr. Fände ich auf jeden Fall geil. Weil ich meine, das ist das, was ich mit Papier mache. Und das ist natürlich auch das, was ich an der Stelle davon erwarten wollte, wenn man das irgendwie richtig, wenn man das eben richtig machen will. Also das war mir einfach zu unterkomplex. Da war einfach nicht...
Hast du Unterkomplex?
Da muss einfach... Also vor allem, das hat mich halt angestartet und halt gesagt, Alter, ich bin einfach ich bin trotzdem noch ein Computer. Ich hab dir jetzt zwar für 1200 Dollar plus nochmal 100 für den scheiß Stift und nochmal keine Ahnung, wie viel 300 Euro, die mittlerweile nur für diesen blöden Cover nehmen. Ja, da hast du so viel Kohle abgelegt, aber du kriegst halt noch nicht mal einen ordentlichen Bleistift symbolisiert. Ich meine, das ist dann auch irgendwie, den du irgendwie für 2,50 im Set kaufen kannst. Das ist einfach mal...
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall eine Sache...
Dann sollen sie es nicht Pencil nennen, sondern sollen sie es Pen nennen.
Vielleicht hast du auch nicht die richtige Abgabe.
Ja, sag ich ja gerade. Es ist ein Softwareding. Und dann bin ich halt in diese Sketch-App gegangen, die ja so... Ja, die kommt ja dann so ganz, wie soll ich sagen, so etwas überkandidelter her. Aber dann war das eigentlich noch enttäuschender als das mit dem Bleistift, weil du dann diese absurden Situation hast, du ziehst also so diesen Pinsel übers Blatt und wenn du, sagen wir mal, jetzt nur so eine gerade Linie machst oder so so leichte Bögen, okay, würde ich sagen, so könnte das theoretisch auch aussehen, wenn ich jetzt so ein Aquarell-Pinsel am Start habe. Könnte sein. Ist allerdings auch unterkomplex, weil es sieht halt immer gleich aus. Es ist einfach nicht random genug. Wo sind da die Unterschiede in den Tints? Wo sind die Unterschiede? Da müssen einfach mal unterschiedlich viele Partikel rausgeflossen kommen. Da ist einfach nicht genug Dreck.
Vor allem, da ist eine Haar, was sich aus dem Ding löst. Genau, keine Haare.
Das ist ja geradezu japanisches Anime. Ein komplett Schamhaar-freies. Kannst du nur so japanische Anime mitmalen. Aber eben keine europäische Kunst.
Da war doch irgendwas drin.
Lass mich doch mal, ich hab mir meine Gedanken gemacht. Wo es aber dann richtig absurd wurde, wenn du dann den Stift langsam geführt hast und dann so eine Kurve nach links und dann so, ah nee, ich mach doch lieber die Kurve nach rechts. Und dann kommt sie halt wieder. Die neunmal kluge Software. Die so, hm, du hast ja so eine Kurve gemacht, ich optimiere das jetzt mal weg. Und dann bewegt sich einfach dieses Schwanzende da von diesem Pinselstrich, so wie so ein wammeliges Stück Gummis. Du bewegst den Stift etwas weiter nach rechts und auf einmal ist ein Bereich, der eben noch bemalt aussah, eben nicht bemalt, weil die Software eben der Meinung ist, du wolltest sozusagen so eine 30 Grad Kurve nach rechts, das hab ich jetzt mal hier so zusammen optimiert aus seinen letzten Strichen, über einen Zeitraum von über einer Sekunde. Also ich kann sozusagen so hin und her wobbeln und dann schlackert irgendwie diese Linie immer hin und her. Und ich meine, so geht das einfach mal nicht mit Farbe. Was drauf ist, ist drauf.
Ja, die müssen die Latenz da wegkriegen und das exakt so machen, wie man da hinpinkelt.
Also Latenz, das Papier muss irgendwie auch kommen. Also das muss einfach einziehen, das muss da drauf sein, das muss auch irgendwie dreidimensional sein. Ich fand zum Beispiel auch diese Bleistift-Fahr, also das, was man da sozusagen gemalt bekommt, wenn du dann so reinzooms, dann hast du da so Pixel. Also das sieht so richtig pixelated aus. Das geht auch gar nicht. Du malst in gewisser Linie auch nur diese Auflösung, die dieser Bildschirm hat. Das ist irgendwie nicht ordentlich vektorisiert.
Und was die größte Enttäuschung war, vielleicht hab ich es auch nur falsch benutzt, aber es war nicht intuitiv, wenn ich es falsch benutzt hab. Lebkuchen sind lecker übrigens. Dass du nicht sagst. Dann wollte ich was radieren. Dann drehste den Stift um.
Das hab ich auch gemacht.
Und ziehst erst mal einen Kratzer über das iPad.
Und ziehst erst mal einen Kratzer über das iPad. Also es fühlt sich so an, als würdest du einen Kratzer über das iPad ziehen und nichts passiert.
Na, es gibt ja Gerüchte, dass bald der Pencil Pro rauskommt.
Nein, der heißt dann bestimmt Magic Pencil.
Magic Pencil Pro 2.
Aber das, was ich noch so dachte, als ich dieses iPad dann auch mal mit der Tastatur benutzte, um so ein bisschen Text zu tippen und so, da dachte ich mir, also entweder dieses MacBook, was nichts kann, oder das iPad Pro, eins von diesen beiden Produkten, wird irgendwann eingestellt werden. Weil irgendwie so richtig, also du hast ja, das iPad ist ja im Prinzip auch ein Computer, wie du schon sagst, mit der Tastatur und allem drum und dran, also wo du nichts ranstecken kannst groß. Keine Ports, kein Nix. Also er hat sogar noch einen Port weniger so gesehen als das MacBook. Und so richtig viel damit machen kannst du auch nicht. Also der Anwendungsfall ist eingeschränkt und irgendwie sind fast die Anwendungsfälle auch ähnlich, würde ich fast sagen, für das MacBook und so ein iPad Pro. Also du hast großen Screen, du hast nicht so viel CPU, du hast eine Tastatur, das ist ultra-portable. Aber so richtig was wuppen kannst du jetzt damit auch nicht.
Mit dem iPad meinst du?
Ja, und auch mit dem MacBook.
Was meinst du, nicht zu wuppen?
Na jetzt nicht halt hier so 30 Audiospuren bearbeiten, Video-Bearbeitung, Zocken, alle was.
30 Audiospuren bearbeiten kannst du damit?
Mit dem iPad oder mit dem MacBook.
Sowohl als auch würde ich sagen.
Du kannst halt kein Interface an das iPad dranhängen. Wo sollen die herkommen, die Spuren?
Na ja, also ja prinzipiell schon auch das.
Das geht.
Ja, aber ich sag mal so, wenn du das renderst, die 30 Spuren, dann dauert es halt einfach ein bisschen länger. Anyway, ist ja auch egal.
Ist ja egal, ich mein, das dauert auf dem MacBook genauso lange.
Ich sag ja auch nur, dass mein Gefühl war, als ich die beiden so, also als ich das benutzt hab, dachte ich mir, hm, also irgendwie so in der Produktpalette von Apple, weiß nicht, ob jetzt beide Produkte wirklich parallel auch Sinn machen.
Ich denk schon. Also zumindest als Übergangsphase. Weil, ich meine, mit dem iPad kannst du halt andere Dinge sehr gut machen, als du mit dem MacBook Pro sehr gut machen kannst.
Nicht MacBook Pro. Ich meine ja nur speziell das MacBook. Das mit ohne Ports und allem. Also weißt du so, von...
Ja gut, aber das sind nicht, weiß nicht, die kann man jetzt auch nicht so vergleichen, finde ich.
Naja, aber mit dieser Tastatur. Also ich meine, an wen richtet sich dieses MacBook ohne alles? An so unbedarfte Web-Clicker, die mal was schreiben wollen unterwegs und ein bisschen brausen. Oder? Also was würdest du sagen ist die Zielgruppe von diesem MacBook?
Na zumindest Leute, die eher generische Anwendungsfälle haben in OS X, ohne jetzt viel mit externer Hardware zu arbeiten. Was wahrscheinlich eine ganze Menge Leute sind.
Und ich meine, brausen, E-Mail, chatten, Video gucken, Multimedia-Food, das kannst du ja alles mit dem iPad Pro im Prinzip auch machen und hast vielleicht sogar noch Touch dazu und den Pencil. Aber es ist teurer.
Ja, aber in der ersten Moment, wo ich so einen Dreck-and-Drop-Bedarf habe, ist für mich ein iPad nach wie vor vor der Tür. Also Copy-Paste, das ist irgendwie so, also schon der Copy-Paste-Vorgang ist ein Schmerz, aber mal so eben das, was ich halt auf dem Mac mit Dreck-and-Drop mache.
Der normale User kennt wahrscheinlich Dreck-and-Drop nicht mal.
Der normale User, also der normale Mac-User auf jeden Fall.
Der Otto-Normal-Facetuber.
Na, das hast du doch jetzt nur für die Bingo-Karte gesagt.
Der Otto-Normal-Facetuber, der holt sich gerne ein iPad und ist irgendwie zufrieden, der kauft sich halt keinen MacBook. MacBook kauft man sich halt, wenn man irgendwie einen ordentlichen Computer haben will, wenn man programmieren will und wenn man irgendwie...
Ich muss übrigens nochmal nachdenken.
Wenn man weiß, den Wert einer Tastatur zu schätzen.
Wir müssen jetzt mal ganz doll zurückspulen kurz in die letzte Sendung, wo wir diskutiert haben über Xcode auf dem IOS. Kannst du dich erinnern? Und ihr wart alle nicht so überzeugt. Was kam genau bei dem Grube einen Tag später? Bist du hier der Moderator oder ich? Bei der letzten Sendung habe ich gesagt, Xcode auf dem IOS wäre jetzt nicht so unwahrscheinlich. Und Apple will weg von US-Tenden, auch so ein bisschen die Diskussion. Und die wollen das dicht machen. Dann meinte, das würde ja nicht gehen. Man muss ja programmieren. Und programmieren Xcode auf dem IOS, das geht irgendwie gar nicht. Und ein oder zwei Tage später kam bei dem Grube irgendein Artikel, dass es da so gerüchtet wird, dass die schon lange dabei sind, das zu tun. Xcode jetzt auf dem IOS zu bringen, weil das wäre zum Testen auf dem Pro, wo du in einer Hälfte da Xcode und in der anderen Hälfte hast du dein nicht simuliertes Programm, sondern richtig live dein Programm. Und besser die Buggen kannst du halt gar nicht. Richtig mit Touch und allem und drum und dran. Und das ist... Richtig.
Würdest du deinen Arsch drauf verwetten?
Nääääh, mein Arsch nicht so. Aber andere Sachen vielleicht.
Eine Küchenwaage vielleicht.
Ja, schon eher so.
Wie oft markierst du was mit der Maus, mit dem Texteditor?
Du kannst an dein iPad Pro auch eine Maus oder eine Tastatur anschließen. Das kriegen die doch wohin.
Eine Maus an iPad? Nee.
Die könnten, wenn sie wollten, geht das ganz schnell und so.
Ja, wenn sie das wollten, aber das wollen sie ja nicht. Weil das ist ja sozusagen das Ding, dass sie das halt nicht tun. Es gibt halt keinen Pointing Device auf dem iPad. In iOS gibt es das halt nicht.
Das warten wir mal ab, würde ich sagen. Das warten wir mal ab.
Aber ich finde, das macht Sinn, wenn sie... Also was sie nicht machen werden, ist, dass sie nicht das OS X jetzt plötzlich irgendwie zumachen und die Schraube andrehen. Das können sie den User nicht antun. Was sie aber machen werden, ist, dass immer mehr Geräte halt gar nicht erst mit OS X kommen, sondern halt mit iOS irgendwie und ein bisschen aufgebohrt, sodass man da mehr machen kann. Und ich könnte mir das schon gut vorstellen. Weil die wollen natürlich alles durch ihren eigenen Store durchschieben. Das ist deren Business. Wenn sie das nicht tun, verdienen die ja nichts.
Ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass sie jetzt am Mac nichts verdienen würden.
Ja, am iPhone verdienen die auch schon scheiße viel Geld, aber am Store halt auch noch.
Ja, aber der Store spielt jetzt im Vergleich zu ihren anderen Einnahmen wirklich nur eine untergeordnete Rolle.
Ja, nur auf Sicht von Apple. Wenn du dir die anderen kleinen Firmen anguckst, dann hätten die diesen Store ganz gerne.
Microsoft.
Ich meine, das ist auch bei den Multimilliarden-Dollar-Business schon, auch wenn er bei Apple halt ziemlich klein aussieht. Aber da geht schon auch ein bisschen Geld durch.
Ja, da geht ein bisschen Geld durch. Aber das ist, sagen wir mal, nicht... Ihr Kernprodukt ist nicht der App Store. Sondern der App Store ist ein Mittel zum Zweck. Der Mittel zum Zweck ist, Devices verkaufen, Plattform etablieren und am Ende halt auch mit iCloud vielleicht Kohle zu machen. Wobei auch iCloud eher mehr im Dienste der Hardware ist, als dass es selber sozusagen das primäre Ding ist.
Ich wollte jetzt ja nur mal erwähnen, dass bei dem Gruber da irgendwie sowas auftauchte und dass wir da auch nochmal gucken können, an einem Jahr oder zwei oder wann auch immer, dass man irgendwann so kommt.
Ja, also ich zweifel auch nicht da dran, dass die damit experimentieren. Ich wäre jetzt überrascht, wenn das nächstes Jahr rauskäme, weil ich mir das irgendwie noch nicht so richtig vorstellen kann. Andererseits, mit dem iPad Pro in der Tastatur sind natürlich schon mal Grundlagen gelegt, aber dann muss es sich natürlich auch gelingen, diese typischen Programmierer, insbesondere diese Editorentasks, hinzubekommen. Weil, ich meine, du wirst ja dann schon auch immer noch mit Textdateien arbeiten, wenn es dann nicht so ein Scratch-Interface ist.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie so was, so einen abgespeckten Xcode mit Playground und Swift und zum Rumspielen, das kann ich mir vorstellen, so für...
Swift only....
für Edutainment purposes und Swift only, wie ich schon meinte, Garage-Code-mäßiges Ding, wo du halt so, ja, du kannst halt Code-doubbeln, aber das ist dann kein, das ist nicht wirklich eine echte Xcode-Alternative, sondern das ist mehr so ein Einsteiger-Ding zum Rumspielen.
So ein Test-Ding und vielleicht so kleine Fixes, die man dann in seinem Test gleich fixen kann, die großen Sachen macht man woanders. Oder vielleicht ist das ja auch sogar gesyncht mit einem richtigen Xcode irgendwie und...
Ja, wird Zeit, dass sie den Distributed Compile mal wieder ausgraben. Das war so schön damals. Aber gib mir mal noch so ein Dingster.
Wir müssen unbedingt mal diese Kekse loben. Konfiserie Rosner.
Genau, empfohlen von der Nina Hagen des Adels, haben wir vorhin festgestellt. Ihr dürft jetzt selber raten, wer das ist.
Waldsassner Kirchturmspitzen. Feinstes Mandelgebäck.
Ja, das hat so was von einer bisschen luftigeren Variante von Marzipan.
Stimmt.
Ist ja nicht nur Marzipan.
Ja, schon, aber es schmeckt sehr Marzipan.
Es ist halt Mandel. Ja, selber schuld, ihr habt uns ja hier irgendwie Essen geschickt, jetzt müsst ihr auch drunter leiden.
Marzipan, Zucker, Mandeln, Nüsse, Eiweiß und feinste Gewürze, die man auch wirklich durch riecht.
Ja, haben wir noch was anzumerken zu diesem iPad Pro? Also siehst du für dich irgendeine Anwendung?
Nein. Also, ich hätte eine, aber das ist schon fast ein Themensprung. Denn ich hab mich... Ja, ich hab nämlich letztens rausgefunden, dass es für so diese DAWs, diese Digital Audio Workstations, also sowas wie Reaper oder Logic oder so, gibt es ja diese Control Surfaces auch, also so Bedienfelder, wie auch immer, Apps fürs iPad oder ein iPhone, um die Fernseher zu steuern. Also die ganzen Fader und so, kannst du dir dann auf dein iPad holen und dann... Und letztens, als ich mal tatsächlich ein paar Spuren mehr so am Bearbeiten war und so, dann bin ich da bei einer Forum-Suche oder so da drauf gestoßen und dachte mir, hm, ok, dafür wäre jetzt so ein iPad eigentlich doch ganz schick, ob ich mir jetzt ein iPad Pro dafür kaufen würde. Das sei mal stark dahingestellt. Aber ja, also abgesehen davon, wie gesagt, entweder, ich würde wahrscheinlich dann im Zweifel mir doch eher ein MacBook kaufen nochmal, so ein billiges, um noch ein Zweit-Device zu haben für verschiedenste Dinge. Ich wüsste jetzt nicht. Und vor allen Dingen das nächste Problem war halt auch das, was Roddy ja auch schon ein paar Mal angemerkt hat, irgendwie dadurch, dass dieser App-Store und das ganze Ökosystem da mit hier von wegen Pro-Apps und Upgrade-Fahrt und keine Ahnung und dies alles nicht so richtig gegeben ist. Das ist auch irgendwie total fragwürdig. Ob da überhaupt die Leute jetzt total drauf abgehen und Apps jetzt nur für das iPad Pro oder so entwickeln? Irgendwie, mich hat das jetzt nicht so sehr geschockt. Und ich wüsste auch jetzt nicht, welche Branche oder welche Anwendungsfall unbedingt jetzt ein iPad Pro braucht und das nicht mit einem normalen iPad oder einem iMac am Ende dann lösen kann.
Ja, Apple hat da einen fiesen Schachzug geliefert, nämlich du kannst für das iPad Pro, für die native Auflösung nur dann benutzen, wenn du tatsächlich das iOS 9 iPad Multitasking unterstützt. Und das ist gar nicht so einfach. Das Problem ist, also wenn du von rechts rein swipes, dann bekommst du erst mal diese Ansicht, dieses Overlay-Ding. Slide over. Slide over, genau. Und wenn du dann weiter slides, dann bekommst du ja zwei Apps nebeneinander. Und wenn du noch mal weiter swipes, dann kann es sein, dass deine App zum Schluss vollscreen ist. Und das hat aber zur Folge, dass deine App es abkönnen muss, dass sie, während sie läuft, ihre Größe ändert. Und das gab es vor iOS 9 nicht bei iOS-Apps, dass die ihre Größe ändern. Also genau genommen ihre Size Class. Es gibt diese Compact Size Class, die so aussieht wie iPhone. Und diese Regular Size Class, die so nach iPad aussieht. Und du kriegst, wenn die sich ändert, kriegst du halt in jedem View so ein Event. Size Class hat sich jetzt geändert. Alles umbauen. Je nachdem, wie man sein Programm so gebaut hat, das kann Kopfschmerzen erzeugen und fiese Crashes. Also das ist so, das ist ein bisschen gemein, dass beides aneinandergehängt haben. Auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, das Multitasking will man eigentlich eh unterstützen. Es sei denn, du bist halt ein Fullscreen-Spiel, das immer Fullscreen ist, weil du halt nur dieses Spiel spielst und sonst nichts tust. Aber alle anderen Apps, die müssen irgendwie co-existieren lernen.
Ich find das gut.
Ja, im Prinzip schon, aber es ist viel Arbeit. Je nach Codebase.
Also ich hätte auch jetzt so keine unmittelbare Anwendung fürs iPad, weil ich hab ja auch schon für meinen anderen iPads eigentlich keine unmittelbaren Anwendungen, außer eine Uhr und TouchOSC. Deswegen bin ich auch nach wie vor mehr auf der Suche nach alten iPads und bin immer noch schockiert, was für Preise die erzielen. Also mir hat es bisher noch nicht gelungen, ein iPad 1 für unter 50 Euro.
Na du hast aber auch Vorstellung.
Das ist Hightech, man.
Ja klar, das ist Hightech, aber es fährt halt iOS 5. Ist schon gefühlt seit... Wann kam das Ding raus? 2009? Das iPad 1?
Kurz vor dem iPad 2. Und auf dem iPad 2 läuft immer noch iOS 9. Das ist etwas, was ich total abstrus finde.
Jaja, naja, das war halt echt ein Prototyp, dieses erste iPad.
Ja, ich hab auch noch eins, ich kann das bestätigen.
Was war das erste? Das erste war 2010. Januar 2010. Nee, ist gar nicht so lange her, aber fühlt sich schon an wie eine Ewigkeit.
Fünf Jahre in der Tech-Welt sind doch schon zwei Weltkriege her, oder?
Klar, mir ist das auch wohl bewusst. Trotzdem würde man halt meinen, dass dieses Gerät mittlerweile einfach wirklich nur noch Ausschuss ist sozusagen. Ja, das ist keiner ernsthaft mehr benutzt, aber offensichtlich nicht.
Na ja, es hat einen fetten Akku, der nicht so schnell kaputt geht.
Man kann ja auch nicht so viel damit machen.
Na ja, man kann schon gute Sachen damit machen. Also das ist eine super Uhr.
Die diversen Mediathek-Apps funktionieren da drauf.
Kauft ihr mal eine geile Wanduhr in dem Format, die schick aussieht, die gut funktioniert.
Da kriegst du aber drei von den alten iPads.
Da bist du halt einfach in diesem Bereich. Da kann man auch gleich ein iPad nehmen.
Diese Clock 2, also geschrieben Q-L-O-C-K, die kostet ja irgendwie 1,5 oder so, wenn man die normal kauft, so die billigste. Clock 2, das ist so eine, da steht es ist fünf.
Ja gut, nicht ganz meine Vorstellung von Ergonomie, aber lustig.
Ja, nee, also es dauert immer etwas, bis man die Zeit abgelesen hat. Aber wie du meintest, lustig. Und die kosten richtig. Aber schick?
Ja, es gibt auch auch so eine komische Uhr, wo die ganze Zeit immer so ein Video siehst von irgendwelchen Leuten, die auf einer Wiese zusammen gehen.
Das ist die Leiter da und der ist bei mir in der Tucholki-Straße und einen so ein Fenster so.
Ja, das kannst du als Video kaufen. Das kannst du als DVD kaufen.
Nee, das gibt es auch als App.
Ja, ja, als App. Aber die App braucht aber die DVD. Was? Ja, du kannst sie ja auch fürs iPad runterladen, aber es sind halt mehrere Gigs.
Es gibt auch eine Uhr, wo jede halbe und volle Stunde ein Vogel aus einer Tür rauskommt und Kuckuck ruft. Ja, das ist auch irgendwie, dass ich das ausgedacht habe.
Das ist ja wirklich schockig.
Das muss südlich zum Beispiel, das muss in Äquatus gewesen sein.
Ich meine, wenn man solche Konzepte so abstrakt beschreibt, dann denkt man sich auch schon manchmal, was haben die eigentlich geraucht?
Naja, falls jemand von euch für einen günstigen Preis noch irgendwie ein paar alte iPads rumliegen hat, wobei noch schärfer wäre ich ja eigentlich auf die Minis. Und die erzielen einfach nochmal so richtig korrekte Preise. Naja, also iPad Pro, schön, dass du da bist.
Wir nehmen dich zur Kenntnis.
Wir nehmen dich zur Kenntnis. Das mit dem Schiff ist irgendwie ganz geil, aber dann guck ich doch mal lieber nicht, ob nicht vielleicht das iPad Mini nächstes Jahr auch mit im Spiel ist. Dann wird es irgendwie ganz interessant, weil das wäre so die richtige Notizgröße für mich. iPad Mini Pro Extreme.
Ultra Ultimate Edition.
Ultimate Edition. Genau, jetzt mit Pencil. Und vor allem will ich halt eine richtige Notizblock-App haben, die sich einfach mal genauso verhält wie Papier.
Und zwar genauso.
Ich will ja mit diesem Bleistift immer so reingedrückt und so weiter. Und ich wollte, dass es schwerzer wird. Es wurde einfach nicht schwerzer.
Soll doch, die Spitze ist abgebrochen. So echt war's.
The tip is broken when you need it. Das wär vielleicht ja auch nochmal ganz nett, diesen Effekt zu machen.
Du meinst, du machst es knack und dann fliegt das Teil über.
Also das iPad gibt so einen lauten Knack laut von sich. Du hast dann auch so eine Schliere und so ein Verzuch und jeder erschreckt sich.
Klingt total...
Mit ein bisschen Glück kriegen die nächsten iPads auch eine Taptic Engine.
Ja, dann hast du auch noch...
Dann kannst du immer richtig knacken.
Force-Touch.
Lass knacken.
Wobei, ich glaub Taptic Engine, ich weiß nicht, ob das funktionieren würde auf diesem großen Screen. Wie willst du denn das machen?
Da müssen wir das halt mal so machen, wie sie es jetzt beim iPad Pro mit den Lautsprechern gemacht haben. Vier Taptic Engines in den Ecken. Und dann wird aber getappt. Bis der Arzt kommt.
Na gut, wir können das mit dem iPad abschließen. Sehr viel mehr kommt da nicht. Oder hat noch irgendjemand Fragen? Aber das mit dem Glasschiff, das hat mich schon ein bisschen geärgert.
Der Zorn sitzt tief. Der Stachel des Zorns.
Ja, tu mal was.
Ich war shoppen. Ich habe geschoppt. Ja, also ich will ja schon seit Juli wurde angekündigt von Super Michael zumindest, dass die ein neues Board rausbringen mit dem allerneuesten Atomchip von Intel drauf. Der heißt N3700. Und den wollte ich haben, den gab es aber monatelang nicht.
Was ist denn denn so toll?
Das ist halt ein Atom. Wir haben ja hier keinen Routerzwang mehr, und wir hatten ihn ja früher auch nicht. Das heißt, ich hab zu Hause halt nicht, mein Modem macht nicht mein Netz, sondern ich hab da halt meinen FreeBSD dahinter. Das läuft auf einer Atomkiste. Meine alte hieß D510 und war halt ein Atom von 2009 oder 2010. Und verbraucht halt richtig wenig Strom. Hab da zwei Platten dran, da ist mein Mirror drauf, ZFS natürlich. FreeBSD hab ich schon gesagt. Und dann kommt auch mein Backup drauf. Das ist sozusagen meine Kiste. Die läuft irgendwie rund um die Uhr.
Ein Homeserver sozusagen.
Genau, Homeserver, Router, Schnick Schnack, irgendwie so. Und der muss halt wenig Strom verbrauchen, weil der läuft halt 24-7. Da spielt irgendwie, jedes Watt spielt irgendwie eine Rolle. Und das war in letzter Zeit halt so ein bisschen langsam, weil die Jahre vergingen. Und da musste mal was Neues her. Auch weil mein altes Atombot hatte nur einmal GIG Ethernet. Und da ich ja ein internes Netz brauche und einmal für das PPoE brauchte ich zwei. Und da war mal so eine Karte drin, die ist mir irgendwann ausgefallen. Jedenfalls hatte ich kein ordentliches schnelles Netz mehr zu Hause. Und ich dachte, bevor ich da jetzt eine neue Karte hole für den, kaufe ich mir ein neues Board mit einem sparsameren und schnelleren Atom mit zweimal Ethernet. Und dann kam halt von Supermicro dieses Board. Im Juli habe ich bestellt, kam nicht, ging nicht und nichts. Und dann habe ich es jetzt vor einer Weile noch mal bestellt. Jetzt gab es sie tatsächlich und kam jetzt. Das ist eine CPU mit vier Kern, also vier Quad-Core. Genau, ohne Hyper-Srlgen, komischweise, warum auch immer. Das Board hat viermal gegen Ethernet irgendwie drauf. Man kann es auch mit zweimal kaufen, aber kostet nur zehn Euro weniger. Das ist scheiße toll, das ist Supermicro, das ist so Server-Scheiße eigentlich. Kann man auch von anderen Firmen kaufen, habe ich geguckt, gibt es von ASRock auch. Und der Chip selbst verbraucht maximal sechs Watt, die CPU. Vier Kerne mit AIS, irgendwie Support und allem Drum und Dran. Und das Board braucht natürlich, weil es halt noch ein bisschen hier Chipsats und Zeug hat und die Platten, die dran sind. Also am Ende sind es schon so knappe 30 Watt, die ich brauche. Da kann man vielleicht noch ein bisschen tunen mit einem Netzteil, was nicht so riesengroß fett ist. Ich habe da gerade eins für 650 Watt dran, aber das... Ich brauche nur 30, also da kann man noch ein bisschen downsizing. Aber das ist so, wenn man halt wirklich sich was bauen will, wo man weiß, das steht jetzt die nächsten fünf Jahre auf meinem Küchenschrank, dann willst du wirklich an jedem Watt sparen. Und dann ist das Ding gerade so state of the art für Low-Power-Computing, wenn man halt so ein bisschen Bums braucht, aber halt nicht zu viel. Ja, die sind da gerade ganz dick dabei, auch hier Arm 64 zu unterstützen. Da hat Apple ja vorgelegt, vor wann war das? Zwei Jahren schon. Die kommen jetzt alle so ein bisschen hinterher. Und Fribierstier macht da auch viel, weil da gibt es eine Bude, die haben irgendwie, ja ich weiß, es sind irgendwie mehrere Bude, die zusammenarbeiten. Es gibt eine Hardware-Firma, Kavium heißen die, glaube ich. Die haben ein Board, das heißt Thunder X. Hab ich jetzt TH? War das richtig? Und das ist ein Armstein, der hat 48 Kerne. Und auf dem Board, was sie haben, können zwei da drauf. Das heißt, du hast so 96 Kerne am Motherboard. Und dafür schreiben, da schreibt so eine Bude. Bei FreeBSD gerade ganz viel Treiberkram und so weiter, dass das da halt funktioniert. Ich hab leider noch keinen Preis gesehen von diesem Ding, aber das ist wohl was so fürs Rechenzentrum, wenn man ganz viele Users mit Virtual Images oder was auch immer, die da genau fahren. Also bei 96 Kerne kriegst du ja alleine gar nicht mehr ausgelastet. Da brauchst du schon ein bisschen was irgendwie.
Da gab es doch so einen Hoster, der genau solche Instanzen irgendwie günstig vercheckt hat. Und dann wollten sie wohl mal ihre Infrastruktur befüllen und haben irgendwie für einen Dollar oder Euro im Monat quasi so eine Instanz rausgetan. Und das war dann innerhalb eines Tages alles weg. Und jetzt, wenn man klickte wohl, ein Kollege wollte das haben, meinten sie so, ja, unser RIG ist jetzt ausgelastet, dauert jetzt einen Moment, bis wir die nächsten... Ja, aber es scheinen schon, sozusagen, so eine Geschäfte gibt es schon, ja.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, dieses Armbot ist auch... weil die meisten Armbots sind ja mal so ein bisschen dünn bestückt irgendwie, aber da stand auch da, das ist richtig mit auch hier so 128 GB Speicher, richtig fett, SATA und Memory ist auch irgendwie gleich so das rechts unten, also ist alles so in fett so Server-Style und nicht so Raspberry Pi-Style. Und ja, wie gesagt, ich hab noch keinen Preis gefunden, das ist wahrscheinlich überhaupt gar nichts für zu Hause. Also ich wüsste nicht, wie ich 48 Kerne auslasten sollte. Aber es würde mich trotzdem mal interessieren, so das Feeling auf so einer Kiste. Nee, aber FreeBestie läuft auf Arm, ja. FreeBestie gibt's auch, Beagle-Bone-Images wohl und Raspberry Pi-Images gibt's glaub ich auch.
Und denkst du, dass das mal eine Option für dich wär? Wenn's hier um Stromsparen geht?
Raspberry Pi und, nee, die haben...
Nur überhaupt irgendeine Armplattform, die hat 90 Kerne, ist jetzt vielleicht...
Was ich halt immer brauche, ist zweimal SATA, zweimal Ethernet. Weil ich brauch halt mein PPOE und mein internes Netz und dann mindestens, mein Backup ist natürlich auf Mürrer-Platten. Und das bräuchte ich schon irgendwie. Ohne das geht's halt nicht. Und die meisten haben entweder nur zweimal Ethernet und einmal SATA oder andersrum, aber meistens sind die beides. Oder weder noch sogar, und dann reicht mir das nicht. Und jetzt hab ich erst mal dieses Ding, das muss jetzt erst mal 5, 6 Jahre durchhalten, so wie man ein altes Atom baut. Das muss ja auch nicht schnell sein, das macht ja eigentlich die ganze Zeit nichts, außer Pakete routen und ab und zu mal Backup und dann vielleicht mal so als Shell-Server irgendwie so ein bisschen spielen oder so. Aber im Großen und Ganzen muss das jetzt nicht allzu viel machen. Okay, ich hab noch ein Bitcoin da rund um die Uhr laufen, jetzt seit ein paar Weile, aber der macht ja eigentlich auch nicht so viel, außer Platzverbrauch.
Was könntest du mit 96 Kern machen?
Naja, nicht so richtig, weil Bitcoin kriegt er die ganze Zeit, also alle 10 Minuten im Blog und so, kriegt er die ganze Zeit so einzelne Transactions rein, die werden kurz gecheckt, dafür reicht mehr oder weniger ein Thread, weil es ja nur eine Transaction. Und dann, wenn halt so ein Blog reinkommt, der hat, sagen wir mal, 1000 Transactions drin, die müssen dann gecheckt werden. Die verteilen das schon auf ganz viele Threads irgendwie, aber...
Da war das TH jetzt nicht so super.
Aber... Ich weiß nicht, ob für die eine Sekunde, wo der da diesen Blog checkt, ob man da dann so viele Kerne draufschmeißt und die ganze andere Zeit da langweilen, die sich dann... Also irgendwann muss man dann doch die schon ausnutzen, damit sich so eine Hardware lohnt. Kommt natürlich auf den Preis an, aber ich denke mal, das Ding wird schon ordentlich was kosten mit 48 Kernen. Das ist auch echt ein Chip, der war nicht mehr klein. Das war schon so wieder wie früher, so ein Pentium-Klopper irgendwie.
War halt 96 Kerne.
Ja, also 48 mal 2. Cavium Thunder X hieß das. Du-du-du. Sonst, wenn man noch als Tipps für Leute, die so was bauen wollen, genau, man soll halt dann eben nicht seine 650 Watt Netzteile nehmen, sondern was Kleineres. Und was es da gibt, ist, es gibt so eine Bude, die macht so Netzteile, die heißen Pico PSU. Das sind gar keine richtigen Netzteile mehr, sondern nur noch so ein Aufsatz für diesen ATX-Stecker. Und da schließt du dann einfach so ein 12 Volt Netzteil an und die erzeugen dann die ganzen 5 und 3,3 Volt und so weiter. Das erzeugen die dann alles. Und die verbrauchen halt wenig Strom. Und das kleinste von denen ist halt mit 80 Watt irgendwie. Und dann geht's hoch bis, keine Ahnung, 2 oder 300. Aber das kann man dann auch nehmen, wenn man sich was ganz, ganz Kleines irgendwie bauen will. Kann man sich dann vorher das Richtige rausnommen, welche Größe man ungefähr braucht und dann nimmt man das.
Mist, ich hab Bitcoin nicht auf meiner Bingo-Karte gehabt.
Da gibt's auch nichts. Kannst du mal die passenden Links zu diesen CPUs und so weiter in den Chat werfen?
Ja, mach ich jetzt im Laufe des Gesprächs, weil Pico, PSU, ich weiß immer gar nicht, wo die alle ihre Seiten haben.
Ja, aber du weißt, wann es wirklich richtig ist.
Kann ich machen.
So, wie machen wir weiter? Weltraum oder Games?
Für 200, bitte.
Weltraum ist immer gut.
Weltraum oder Games?
Auf unserem Podcast-Workshop hatten wir auch einen Podcast der Jeopardy!
Wo hast du denn da Weltraum?
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Nee, gesehen nicht. Ich hab's nur gelesen. Ich bin ja mehr Fan von der anderen Firma, deswegen hab ich das wegignoriert.
Machst du mal ein bisschen leiser hier. Die haben ja irgendwie so ein etwas übertriebenes Video gemacht, aber ich hatte die auch überhaupt nicht auf dem Zeiger in die Bude.
Ich auch nicht.
Also Blue Origin war mir jetzt mal echt total neu, aber die sind auch glaube ich eher so im Tourismus.
Jaja, die fliegen einmal geradeaus ins Vakuum nach oben.
Ja, genau.
Und dann landen sie wieder. Also ich meine, das was SpaceX dahin kriegt, also was in den Orbit schießen und dann die unterste Stufe irgendwie versuchen zu landen, ist halt doch nochmal ein anderes Ticket irgendwie. Also als nur geradeaus nach oben zu fliegen und wieder runter.
Das ist ja das Ding. Die landen auch.
Jaja, die landen auch. Aber? Aber die fliegen nur geradeaus nach oben, die machen keinen Orbit.
Achso, achso, du meinst, okay. Re-Entry hast du ja trotzdem bei 100 Kilometern Höhe.
Also die Konferenzfirma ist ja SpaceX, die das machen mit dem Grasshopper. Mit dem Grasshopper sind die ja schon gelandet, nur die waren noch nicht so weit oben. Und mit ihren echten Raketen, mit denen sie auch Satelliten im Orbit absetzen und dann wieder zurückkommen, das hat bei SpaceX noch nicht geklappt. Und bei denen jetzt schon, wenn ich das richtig gelesen hab, dann gehen sie 100 Kilometer hoch und sind dann von da wieder erfolgreich runter und wieder gelandet, richtig?
Also es ist ein glorifizierter Parabelflug. Mehr ist es nicht.
Kann man jetzt natürlich so sehen, und dieses Video ist auch total mega cheesy, weil sie dann hier noch mit so 3D-Animationen...
Zwischen drinnen und dann fährt da die Kapsel runter.
Aber sie zeigen halt, wie die Kapsel landet. Das ist halt ganz klassisch hier einfach mit Fallschirmen in der Wüste. Aber wie dann halt diese Rakete zurückkommt, das sieht schon wirklich...
Das sieht schon geil aus, ja.
Die sieht jetzt noch mal um? Nein, die launch jetzt... Die kommen in einem Speed nach unten, wo du denkst so Oho, ob das mal gut geht. Und dann so auf den allerletzten Mittag gibt das Ding nochmal so richtig Gas. Da merkt man aber auch, was da für eine Power drin ist. Naja, und dann...
Taumelt aber auch ganz schön, ne? Nochmal richtig Gas, sehr schön langsam und... Spucken aus. Naja, das ich jetzt...
Und auch nicht irgendwo, sondern mal genau auf den Punkt, ne?
Genau neben der Kamera, damit die das schön filmen kann.
Die haben da auch so einen kleinen Landeplatz da. Da steht das Ding einfach mal genau in der Mitte dran.
Na ich bin ja SpaceX-Fan und hab mit dem Grasshopper gesehen und war total hooked sofort und dachte, das ist es. Und ich hab da keine Aktien drin, aber ich bin voll Fan. Ich find's ja schade, dass das da nicht geklappt hat. Aber der kommt da wirklich schnell runter, geschlossen.
Der kommt wirklich scheiße schnell runter. Das ist wirklich, aus der Nähe merkt man es erst so richtig.
Und so werden eines Tages die Alien kommen, so schnell landen und pengen, sofort geht's los. Das sieht schon ganz schön fies aus, so schnell wie das kommt, als wenn es wirklich so ein bisschen intelligent ist, oder?
Du musst natürlich sehen, dass SpaceX mit ihrer Rakete tatsächlich die ISS anfliegt. Und versucht dann aber, als Nebenprodukt die Unterstufe zu landen.
Das schrinken die bestimmt auch hin.
Nur, das Ding ist, die Orbitalgeschwindigkeit ist halt was anderes, als einfach nur geradeaus nach oben zu fliegen. Da gibt's irgendwie, Elon Musk hatte da so einen Tweet, wo er dann nochmal den XKCD dazu zitiert. Ich weiß nicht, ob den jetzt irgendjemand, schmeißt doch jemand mal den XKCD in den Chat. Dieses What-If. Oder da das mal hinrechnen. Ich glaube, das ist ungefähr die 20-fache. Du hast ungefähr die 20-fache Energie, wenn du Orbitalgeschwindigkeit hast. Ja, und diese Energie musst du loswerden. Gut, ich denke mal, dass die SpaceX-Unterstufe nicht unbedingt Orbitalgeschwindigkeit erreicht. Aber sie wird auch ein Teil der Orbitalgeschwindigkeit auch durch einen schrägen Flug versuchen, dem Geschoss mitzugeben. Und hat deswegen wahrscheinlich auch nochmal ganz andere...
Na gut, aber das haben sie ja geschafft. Also bei ihrem Landeversuch waren sie ja... Und sie haben auch viele andere Möglichkeiten.
Die war absorbiert, sie waren da, sie waren fast da, ja.
Und auf den letzten Metern hat es halt irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Hier ist schon der What-If. Ohne Plokollschema. Upsala. Ich bin jetzt verklickezort hier.
War das das Ding mit It is Rocket Science? Und irgendwie so?
Na, es geht um Orbital Speed. Also, ja.
Orbital Geschwindigkeit sagt man.
Orbital Geschwindigkeit, ja. Also, das ist schon keine Ahnung. Ich will jetzt auch nicht das Kleinreden, was die da gemacht haben. Wie heißen sie?
What-ifs sind echt so großartig.
Aber ich mein, dass SpaceX irgendwie an der ISS angedockt hat, ist jetzt irgendwie auch keine kleine Leistung. Das muss man einfach mal so sagen. Dagegen ist mal so ein Demonstrator hochzufliegen.
Wann ist denn bei denen jetzt der nächste Flug? Wann trauen die sich denn?
Das ist alles on hold. Sollte aber jetzt diesen Monat losgehen, aber haben sich verschoben. Aber das ist wohl normal bei Raketendings. Earliestime irgendwie. Also die geben immer den Zeitpunkt an. Das ist der früheste Zeitpunkt, an dem sie losfliegen. Du kennst dich ja da aus, genau. Und dass sie sich dann verschiebt, ist ganz normal.
Aber sie sind im Prinzip schon technisch wieder so weit starten zu können und zu wollen.
Na, die hatten ja diesen Unfall, mussten da ihre Streben verbessern. Ich hab da letztens irgendwo so einen Blog gelesen und die haben da noch was anderes irgendwie verbessert, was damit aber nichts zu tun hat. Und die wollen jetzt wieder loslegen. Und alle Flüge sind dementsprechend jetzt von September oder wann das war ein bisschen verschoben worden, weil sie erstmal hier mit der NASA und der Luftfahrtbehörde was auch immer da irgendwie ihren Unfall einmal durchklären mussten und so. Und die wollen ja demnächst auch mit dem bemannten Raumflug loslegen. Deswegen sind sie da jetzt ein bisschen extra vorsichtig.
Ja, hoffentlich verzögert sich das nicht noch mit der Zukunft alles. Das find ich ein bisschen...
Zukunft verzögert sich immer. Sonst wär's ja schon jetzt da.
Aber nicht immer so viel. Ich will das alles noch mitkriegen. Das muss alles noch stattfinden. In my lifetime. Vor allem so Weltraumfahrstuhl fänd ich ja geil. Stattdessen fahren sie halt jetzt mit Raketen irgendwelche reichen Touristen hoch. Das find ich irgendwie... Das ist so eine Verschwendung.
Aber ist doch schön, wenn die sozusagen die Forschung bezahlen dadurch.
Bestimmt.
Die machen das nicht so einen Selbstkostenpreis.
Naja, aber Forschung, also die Forschung und Forschung, also die bezahlen sicherlich die Kosten, die dieses Unternehmen hat und denen die Gewinne. Aber inwiefern da eben auch wirklich Forschung bei abfällt, das weiß ich nicht. Also es ist sicherlich nicht komplett forschungsfrei, weil auch da sind natürlich kapable Leute unterwegs, die mal das eine oder andere Paper schreiben werden. Und in gewisser Hinsicht ist auch diese ganze wirlandene Rakete umso mehr unabhängigen Unternehmen das gelingt, umso mehr wird sich diese Technik auch etablieren. Das ist schon ganz richtig. Trotzdem finde ich es halt so ein bisschen albern nur, in Einführungsstrichen, nur so reiche Fazkes da sozusagen so einen Aussichtsturm zu bauen. Mit diesem ganzen Aufwand. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt eh schon ins All startet und soviel Sprit investiert, mal wieder die Anziehungskraft der Erde zu überwinden, dann kann man ja vielleicht auch gleich mal was Nützliches tun und nicht den ganzen Nutzen da drin zu haben, dass da so ein paar Pökser da rum sitzen und sagen oh, da, guck mal hier, die Boltenführer.
Aber die investieren ja dadurch auch indirekt in die Forschung, das ist schon okay.
Sinnvoll könnte es nur sein, eigentlich müsste man halt hier so diese ganzen Idioten da hochfliegen. Welche? Na, so Leute, die der Meinung sind, wir hätten kein Klimaproblem und Pipapo. Also was ja das ist ja noch mehr verschwendet. Was ja Astronauten alle immer unisono berichten, ist so dieses, wenn du mal die Erde von oben angeschaut hast, dann ist halt alles anders. Wenn du irgendwie erstmal so mit eigenen Augen gesehen hast, wie dünn unsere Schutzschicht ist gegenüber dem Weltall.
Andererseits wenn du sozusagen das Big Picture hast, ja.
Aber den Leuten kannst du vielleicht für den Start auch erstmal einen schönen LSD-Trip verpassen. Vielleicht reicht das auch schon mal als erste Welt mit anderen Augen und Natur anders kennenlernen.
Zumindest quasseln sie dann noch mehr Quatsch und dann glaubt ihm keiner mehr.
Weißt du, so in Paris in dem Hotel, wo sie jetzt ihre Klimakonferenz machen, einfach mal Trips ins Wasser.
Aber es muss draußen sein in der Natur, sonst hast du ja nichts von diesem The World is Beautiful. Wobei diese ganzen religiösen Fanatiker dann wahrscheinlich auf einen ganz schwierigen Trip kommen.
Ich glaub auch, das ist einfach wenn du da die falschen Mindset hast, dann wird das irgendwie auch nichts. Alles nicht so gesichert.
Halt mir fest, LSD ist keine allgemeine Lösung.
Ihr habt das nicht hier gehört. Wir unterschreiben das nicht.
Holt's aus. Das fies mit dieser Bingo-Karte. Mir liegen die ganze Zeit so ein paar Phrasen schon auf den Lippen, aber ich will es auch jetzt nicht den Leuten zu leicht machen. Für die Zeit halt Mietes, die du auch wirklich nur spielst und danach das auch wieder abbestellst.
Ja, vor allem, wenn du die Ressourcen da besser genutzt. Warum sollst du die ganze Zeit so ein Ding da rumgammeln lassen, um es irgendwie ein paar Stunden mal...
Genau, für einmal im Jahr mal ein bisschen zocken. Und ich mein, das Ding war halt, du streamst halt in 27p dieses Spiel, also das ist halt nicht superkrasse Auflösung, das heißt, das Spiel läuft dann auch auf dem Server nur in 1280 x 800 oder so.
Aber es reicht. Aber 60 Frames, ne?
Ja.
Also zumindest dieses Video, was du hier gerade verlinkt hast, das kommt jetzt von YouTube so.
Genau. Ja, hier siehst du ja auch in diesen Capture-Settings, siehst du auch mit wie viel Frames sozusagen das da durchläuft.
Hast du in letzter Zeit auch mal so ein Spiel gesehen in High Quality und kannst das dann auch vergleichen? Also die Qualität da ist jetzt nicht so super, aber das könnte halt daran liegen, dass es halt YouTube-Videos sind.
Na, sagen wir mal so, ich habe halt bei diesem Fallout 4 schon mal alles hochgedreht und das läuft halt. Ich meine, du spielst das eben auch dann nicht in Full HD, weil du streamst ja eh nur 27p. Das macht dann nicht so mega viel Sinn. Und außerdem ist bei diesem Amazon-Image irgendwie das mit der Auflösung ändern, weil irgendwie so ein bisschen tricky, weil halt kein echtes Display dranhängt und dann manche Spiele denken, oh Moment, da ist gar kein richtiges Display dran, dann gehe ich mal auf die Default-Auflösung. Da muss man so ein bisschen tricksen. Aber was mich halt richtig fasziniert hat, ist, dass die Latenz halt wirklich kaum spürbar ist. Ich würde vielleicht nicht Quake 3 Arena oder so was drauf spielen, also so ein fast FPS-Shooter, aber für Fallout 4 oder so Spiele, die so, sagen wir mal, eine mittlere Geschwindigkeit haben, war das so Mausbewegung schnell hin und her oder Sachen anklicken, war gefühlt instantan. Und das hat mich schon ganz schön weggepustet. Und dieser Typ hat halt so ein Tutorial gemacht. Das werden wir natürlich jetzt hier auch in den Chat schmeißen, wenn es nicht schon in den Chat geschmissen wurde. Ich mach das mal gerade. Und das Geile war halt, die Anleitung ist halt relativ aufwendig, weil er erklärt halt, okay, wie installiere ich die Driver, wie installiere ich einen OpenVPN, wie mache ich die Keys, wie mache ich dies, wie mache ich das, wie mache ich jenes. Und dann dachte ich mir schon, Alter, warum hast du nicht einfach einen Image gemacht? Weil du kannst ja im Amazon Marketplace deine eigenen Images sozusagen auch veröffentlichen. Und natürlich, wenn man den Artikel dann so ein bisschen liest, kann man halt auch einfach das Image im Amazon Marketplace klicken. Ich würde mal sagen, es dauert so trotzdem eine halbe Stunde, bis man das so aufgesetzt hat alles und alle Settings so ein bisschen verstanden hat. Und seinen Tunnelblick irgendwie konfiguriert hat. Also ein paar Steps muss man halt schon noch machen. Und dann hat man es halt am Laufen. Und es funktioniert erstaunlich gut. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das aktuell jetzt wirklich der Weg ist, um zu zocken. Weil bei mir war es dann auch am zweiten Tag, als ich das probiert habe, irgendwann nach anderthalb Stunden war die Verbindung langsam. Und ja, dann ist halt vorbei mit Spielspaß, sondern dann kommt der Frust ganz schnell. Aber so für ein bisschen mehr als ein Proof-of-Concept war ich schon echt beeindruckt, was da so geht. Und diese GPU Large Instance, die kostet in Frankfurt pro Stunde, glaube ich, so um die 90 Cent. Das heißt, wenn ich mir einen PC für 1000 Dollar kaufen würde, hätte ich schon mal rund 1000 Spielstunden, auch auf Amazon erst mal. Und dann hat er halt gesagt, es gibt halt diesen Festpreis, aber es gibt ja auch diese Spot Instances, wo man sozusagen auf den Preis bieten kann. Das heißt, je nach Nachfrage werden die teurer oder billiger. Und du kannst halt sagen, naja, pass mal auf, ich will eine Instanz, die maximal 40 Cent die Stunde kostet. Und dann kriegst du die halt zu dem Preis, solange der Preis nicht überboten wird sozusagen. Also es kann halt sein, dass da mittendrin irgendjemand so...
Auf dem Spiel oder was?
Ich weiß nicht genau wie...
Dann kommt dann irgendwie so der Ritter von rechts und enthauptet einen.
Es kann auch sein, dass entweder der Preis geht dann mithoch oder ich weiß nicht genau, wie das Amazon handhabt, aber er hat hier zum Beispiel eine Spot-Instanz für 11 Cent die Stunde dann sogar geklickt und dann bist du halt...
Man könnte das ja gleich mit dem Spiel verbinden.
Hast du die Spielefirmen das gleich so anbieten meinst?
Nee, du bist ja dann so Abenteurer und musst ja deine Leute slayen und irgendwelche Banken ausrauben oder was das Spiel halt auch immer so ist und je nachdem...
Man killt die anderen Spieler und dann werden die Instanzen billiger, weil die haben dann keinen Bock mehr am Turnier aufzuspielen.
Ja, umso besser du bist, umso billiger wird es sozusagen. Oder andersrum, je nachdem.
Auf jeden Fall war das sozusagen als Vorbereitung für meinen Winterurlaub. War das so die erste Auseinandersetzung mit Spielen und wie mache ich das jetzt mit möglichst wenig Geldaufwand?
Ich muss mich aber nochmal dumm fragen.
Ja, bitte.
Fallout ist was? Ist das, wo man alle erschießen muss?
Nee, das ist so eine Mischung aus... Es hat so Minecraft-Elemente tatsächlich. Es hat so ein bisschen Survival-Spiel-Elemente und Story, halt ganz viel Story. Also es wird auch geschossen, aber meistens auf irgendwelche Aliens oder Zombies oder Ghouls oder irgendwie sowas.
Tim, du kennst doch Elektra, ne? Die hat mir mal die Fallout 3 DVD gegeben, weil sie meint, das Spiel ist so geil. Das müsste dir ja einiges sagen, wenn mir Elektra Fallout 3 gibt.
Also die Story von Fallout ist schon eigentlich ziemlich cool und die Spiele haben auch eigentlich, glaube ich, alle Preise gewonnen, immer wieder und Fallout 4 finde ich schon extrem gut gelungen. Es hat halt so dieses Open-World-Feeling, du kannst überall hinlaufen und überall in der Welt auch mal irgendwas entdecken, was jetzt nicht so auf dem offiziellen Storyplan steht. Und auch so die ganze, das ganze Story-Setup ist eigentlich ganz schick. Also es ist so gedacht, quasi, stell dir vor, so das Amerika der 50er und 60er Jahre, so mit dem ganzen Nuklear-Wahnsinn und aber auch diese, dieses so, ja, alles wird hier so Jetsons-mäßig, ne? So dieser Spirit, der wär nie weg gewesen, also der wär nie durch kalten Krieg und so weiter abgelöst worden, das ist immer so weitergegangen. Und dann irgendwann kommt es halt dazu, dass sich sozusagen die ganze Welt mit Nuklearwaffen beballert und die Leute dann halt irgendwie in irgendwelchen unterirdischen Dingern überleben und dann irgendwann halt rauskommen und die neue, sozusagen die verwüstete Welt jetzt sozusagen umkämpft wird, ja. Und das ist im Prinzip so ein bisschen die Story und ja, es irgendwie macht Spaß, sich da durchzuklicken und zu spielen. Ich stau dich gerade hier über diesen Face Customizer.
Vor allem die Namen dazu sind geil.
Nee, das ist wirklich schön gemacht.
Ohne Oberläppchen.
Ja, kann sogar die Ohren richtig einstellen.
Seid ihr bereit für die nächste Stufe nach diesem Cloud Gaming? Nee, meine nächste Stufe. Weil jetzt hab ich mir gedacht, toll, wenn jetzt an Weihnachten genau dann oder danach, dass das Netz bei mir streikt oder langsam ist oder was auch immer, und ich sitze dann da und schieb nur Frust und kann mich nicht der Welt entziehen und einfach nur zocken.
Hast du also doch einen Rechner gekauft?
Jetzt dachte ich mir, ja okay, auf meinem MacBook kann man, also ich hab mir so einen Guide durchgelesen, wo drin steht, welche Grafiksettings bei Fallout 4 so den größten Unterschied machen. Dann gibt's halt auch schöne Vergleichsvideos. Okay, was büßt du denn wirklich ein an Bildqualität und auch im Vergleich zur Konsole. Und da waren zumindest diverse Hinweise, dass es auf meiner Hardware mit der GeForce 650M eigentlich auch noch ganz gut laufen würde. Aber das Spiel gibt's halt nur für Windows. Ja, und dann dachte ich mir nämlich, okay, ich könnte ja mal dieses Bootcamp ausprobieren, aber ich will Bootcamp nicht auf meiner internen Platte haben. Und dann hab ich so ein bisschen gegoogelt, geht denn Bootcamp auch auf externer Platte? Und da gibt's so tausende Posts im Internet, die sagen, ne, also externe Platte ist schon mal gar nicht, ja? Also wenn, dann überhaupt nur interne Platte und dann so, wie man das so kennt, übliches Foren...
Was wohl nicht geht, ist das vom USB zu booten, oder? Doch. Also nicht mit dem normalen Bootloader, sondern musst dann dieses Read-Net nehmen.
Nee, genau, das ist alles Käse, es geht wunderbar. Es gibt im Apple Support Forum gibt's tatsächlich genau diese Frage, der erste Hit auf Google, wo einer auch antwortet, pass mal auf, hier ist die Anleitung, wie es geht. Und darunter schreiben dann auch noch Leute so, nee, nee, das geht auf gar keinen Fall.
Okay, aber wie kompliziert ist es? Ist es nicht nur anschließen dann, oder?
Nee, du musst halt quasi eine externe Platte, also du musst ein Windows 7 reicht, in der VM booten zum Beispiel. Und von da aus kannst du dann das ISO auf eine externe Platte extrahieren. Also quasi drauf, also so wie zum Beispiel, wenn du von einem FreeBSD-Image das auf die Platte applizierst. Und das geht unter Windows dann. Du musst halt so ein paar funky Commands angeben, um die Platte so zu formatieren, dass man davon booten kann. Aber die Commands sind da alle im Wesentlichen aufgelistet. Du brauchst nur ein Windows ISO, eine externe Platte, USB 3, habe ich in dem Fall benutzt, funktioniert ohne Probleme. Und dann brauchst du auch null Bootcamp, du musst nichts machen, du musst nur in der VM das Image draufkleben. Und dann beim Booten Alt gedrückt halten, dann erscheinen diese Windows-Platte, dann bootest du davon, steckst einen USB-Stick mit den Bootcamp-Drivern rein.
Man muss aber schon ein bisschen was machen, weil ich hab das auch probiert und das ging halt eben nicht. Ich hab das Windows auf einer normalen Platte, das war auch vor einem Original-PC, also so wie man halt so Windows installiert, ganz normale Windows-Platte, hab die in meinen Mac Pro gesteckt, also intern halt so in diesen SATA-Slot und davon kann sie booten, aber extern angeschlossen an eine Mac Pro per USB, gleiche Platte, konnte man nicht booten. Das heißt, du musst da schon anscheinend ein bisschen was ändern.
Naja, warte, pass auf, ich pack mal diesen Link in den Chat, vielleicht kann ich den Tim ja mal ganz kurz aufmachen hier.
Weil ich glaub, das wär schon für viele Leute interessant, wie man Windows auch per USB mal schnell booten kann, weil man's eben nicht auf seiner internen haben will.
Und hier, der Typ fragt, is it possible, what equipment do you need? Und dann kommt hier der erste Post gleich ganz oben, was du halt machen musst. Und im Wesentlichen, du musst halt einmal diese Tools runterladen, um das ISO-Image auf die Platte zu bringen, in der richtigen Form. Dann stehen hier diese Command-Prompt, Commandos drin, wie du die Platte hier unten so partitionierst und so weiter und so fort. Und dann, es kommt mal ein Stück runter, Tim, dann gibt's da ein Command hier unten, Now we'll make the USB drive bootable. Noch einen Command da in den Command-Prompt eingetippt und es geht auch relativ flott alles. Und das war's dann wirklich. Also, der ganze Kram dauert, weiß nicht, ich hab eine SSD über USB 3 angeschlossen, auf die ich das extrahiert hab, das hat, glaub ich, insgesamt alles mitlesen. Hat alles so irgendwie vielleicht 20 Minuten gedauert. Dann brauchte ich natürlich noch ein Windows-Image mit irgendeiner Serie, da hab ich mir einfach irgendwie auch aus dem Internet jetzt so ein Windows 10 für 50 Euro geklickt. Nee, ich hab hier auf so einer idealo.de einfach Windows 10 geguckt und es gibt Windows 10 Download-Only-Lizenz für 50...
Aber Windows 10 kostet doch nichts mehr.
Doch, das kostet was.
Kostet nur nichts, wenn du vorher schon Windows 9, 8, ne, 9 gab's ja nicht, 8 oder 7 hattest. Dann war das Upgrade kostenlos. Aber wenn du jetzt neu und jetzt auch mal die Welt, die Windows Welt für dich entdecken willst und mit den anderen coolen Kids unterwegs sein willst, dann...
Und ich muss dir mal sagen, ich hab noch nie Bootcamp oder irgendwas anderes hier auf dem Mac gebootet, außer...
Und wie war die Erfahrung so?
Als ich diese Alt-Taste drückte und dann kam so Windows-Discs und ich hab die so angeklickt und dann kam erst mal original schwarzer Screen mit weißem Blank-Cursor links oben, der geblinkt hat. Ich dachte mir so... Und dann kam halt dieser Windows- Boot-Screen und so. Ich mein, man muss sagen, Windows 10, also ich hatte echt schlimme Auserwarte, das sieht schon ganz schick aus für ein Windows. Also ich glaube, das ist das schickste Windows, was ich bisher so gesehen hab. Also auch so von der Boot-Experience abgesehen von dem ersten. Das war auch nur beim ersten Mal booten. Dass dieses Blinky-Blinky da kam. Aber ab dann ging's sofort mit Fancy-Schmancy-Blue und Fenster hier und Fenster da und so weiter. Ja, und also wenn jemand sozusagen Bootcamp-Windows haben will, ohne Bootcamp, also ohne die primäre interne Platte zu zepartitionieren und so weiter, dann dieser Guide. Ich wollte den noch mal auf meinem Blog cross-posten, weil einige Schritte von diesem Formatieren und Partitionieren, die sind so ein bisschen missverständlich. Ich glaube, die sind für Windows 8 und unter Windows 7 sind die ein kleines bisschen anders, diese Befehle. ansonsten hat das echt wunderbar direkt funktioniert und das geile ist, in dem gleichen Post weiter unten, dann sagen die Leute, nein, auf gar keinen Fall und du brauchst also mindestens Thunderbolt oder die Platte muss GPT-partitioniert sein, sonst geht es überhaupt gar nicht und es ist einfach MBR der einfach... Master Boot Record Total 0815 muss nix installieren, das Ding kommt einfach hoch und das Einzige, was man dann eben tun muss und das kann man eben mit dem Bootcamp Utility machen, dass du dir einen USB-Stick mit den Treibern anfertigst und das Schöne ist, obwohl ich nicht die neueste Bootcamp-Version habe, weil ich ja ein altes, obwohl, warte mal, müsste ich eigentlich mal gucken. Ich habe ja noch Jose Mita auf meiner Kiste und ich glaube, Sie haben Windows 10 Support mit der Bootcamp 6-Version irgendwie genommen. Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ob ich hier Bootcamp eigentlich auch 6 schon habe, durch irgendein System-Update. Auf jeden Fall hat auch auf Jose Mita dieses Bootcamp Utility, die Windows 10-Driver und alles am Start gehabt. Nee, ich habe sogar 5.1.4 noch, aber er hat dann trotzdem aus dem Internet sozusagen das neueste Driver-Package runtergeladen und funktioniert.
Also ich hatte bei meinem alten Mac einfach also nur das Problem, dass man da eine ganz bestimmte Boot- Loader-Datei irgendwie aus diesem Windows da raus friemeln.
Das war wahrscheinlich genau dieses eine Kommando, was jetzt wieder unten rausgescrollt ist, um zu sagen, mach mal EFI. Da ist der Ordner, wo es losgeht. Das war gestern Abend, als ich nach Hause gekommen bin, nach Proberaum und nach mir, fuck it, jetzt probier ich das mal und dann, ah scheiße, erst Windows ISO runterladen. Aber man muss auch sagen, Microsoft hat auch echt so ein paar Sachen geregelt bekommen. Wenn du jetzt suchst Windows 10 ISO, kommt es heute auf die Microsoft-Seite und du kannst einfach ein ISO runterladen. In X64, in der Sprache, kommt auch mit Wirespeed reingeflogen und du kannst es auch installieren ohne Product Key und sagen, ihr nervt mich später nochmal. Also du musst gar nicht irgendwie auf irgendein komisches Torrent gehen und so weiter, sondern ladet euch das dann im Zweifel einfach gleich von Microsoft runter und zum Testen könnt ihr das halt ohne Product Key und ohne Lizenz machen. Und ich habe mir nur die Lizenz eigentlich gekauft, weil ich sowieso eine VM haben wollte, mal mit einem etwas aktuelleren Windows. Und das sowieso brauchte sozusagen. Und jetzt habe ich hier so Windows 10 auch, auf meiner Externplatte. Krass.
Und du benutzt das jetzt zum Gameen.
Der eigentliche Test, ob jetzt Fallout 4 auch wirklich flüssig genug läuft, der steht noch aus. Aber ich packe jetzt noch für die Leute, die auch Bock auf Fallout 4 haben, auf ihr Mac, weil gerade auch so zum Beispiel die iMacs sind ja eigentlich coole Devices zum Gameen, abgesehen von der Grafikkarte, die halt ein bisschen schwachbrüstig ist. Und da gibt es hier einen sehr schönen Artikel, Blogpost, was auch immer, packe ich in die Show Notes, wo sozusagen die ganzen Grafikeinstellungen verglichen werden und auch gesagt wird, welche am größten Performance Impact haben auf das Spiel und auch eine schöne Auflistung haben. Wenn man in Full HD mit 60 FPS spielen will, dann braucht man Hardware im Wert von XY. Und haben das wirklich sehr, sehr nüchtern und schön aufgeschlüsselt und wie gesagt, also ich hab Hoffnung, dass es auf meiner Maschine dann auch immer noch einigermaßen cool läuft.
Survival oder Kill, Kill, Kill oder?
Ja, nee, es ist halt so, es gibt halt verschiedene, also du bist halt einer, der in so einem unterirdischen Bunker war während des Krieges und du warst halt so eingefroren, 200 Jahre. Kommst halt nach 200 Jahren, wachst da auf, deine Frau, die in der Nachbarzelle war, ist tot, dein Baby war es auch mit dabei, war es weg und du wachst jetzt in diesem verlassenen Bunker auf, gehst an die Oberfläche und stellst fest, oh, nuklearer Krieg, 200 Jahre später sieht jetzt nicht so lustig aus. Und da ist halt sozusagen ein Part, ist sozusagen Survival erstmal in dieser Welt, ne? Und dann gibt's verschiedene Story-Strenger, also du kannst dich sozusagen mit verschiedenen Fraktionen dann irgendwie assoziieren und sagen, ja, ich will jetzt das machen, ich will jetzt das machen. Es gibt super viele Open-World- Sachen, wo du einfach nur rumläufst und Sachen findest. Es gibt halt so ein bisschen Crafting, so wie in Minecraft. Ja, du kannst irgendwie deine Waffen, die du findest, irgendwie mit irgendwelchen Zeug wieder besser machen oder du kannst auch ganze Häuser bauen, wenn du lustig bist. Es gibt da wirklich so verschiedene Ansätze für jeden, sag mal für verschiedene Spielertypen. Leute, die nur Bock auf Story haben, die können das halt auch rein Story-lastig spielen. Leute, die Bock auf Alien schießen oder nicht Alien, aber Zombie schießen haben und so weiter, die können halt auch ein bisschen die Baller-Richtung spielen sozusagen. Und Leute, die Bock auf Bauen haben, die können halt sich mit so ein paar Siedlern anfreuen und dann halt einfach eine Basis bauen und sich gegen die Zombies mit der Basis verteidigen. Deswegen, und die Welt ist halt episch riesig und super viele Details und es ist wirklich unfassbar. Cool gemacht. Genau, und hier, Tim probiert jetzt gerade sozusagen, auf diesem Blogpost gibt's auch wirklich schöne Overlay-Grafiken, wo man selber dann den Slider hin und her schieben kann, um zu sehen, was jetzt diese Grafikeinstellungen wirklich letztendlich für einen Effekt machen.
Ja, weil ich mich wundere, dass das irgendwie so Shadow und Distance, ok. Teilweise sehe ich hier gar keinen Unterschied oder weiß gar nicht, was ich besser finden soll.
Du musst da im Hintergrund gucken.
Aber genau deswegen finde ich diesen Blogpost halt so cool, weil die halt nicht sagen ja, du brauchst jetzt hier, klick mal diesen Affiliate-Link auf diese Grafikkarte und so weiter und so fort, sondern halt auch sagen hier diese Godrays zum Beispiel, die sehen in der billigsten Einstellung und in der höchsten Einstellung fast keinen Unterschied. Die haben einen relativ hohen Einfluss auf die Performance, glaube ich 40% oder so. Und man sieht halt fast nichts davon. Und deswegen ist genau so eine Post dann halt wirklich cool für Leute, die ein bisschen zocken wollen, aber jetzt nicht gleich für einmal im Jahr zocken 1000 Euro PC kaufen.
Glaubst du denn, um nochmal kurz auf diesen Aspekt von dem Cloud-Gaming zurückzukommen? Ich überlege mir jetzt gerade, wenn... Also gibt's das nicht ohnehin schon? Es gibt doch sozusagen schon dieses gestreamte Gamespielen auf irgendwelchen VMs?
Gibt's doch auch schon? Cloud-Gaming hat glaube ich eine eigene Seite in der Wikipedia, wo alle möglichen schon Unternehmungen und Projekte zu diesem Thema auch aufgelistet werden. Ganz viele sind aber noch... Also wollen entweder nur so Technologie-Provider sein und gar nicht mit Endkunden zu tun haben, sondern eher hier Amazon implementiert auch mal das oder keine Ahnung, also irgendwie so Mittelsmann oder Technologie- Anbieter sein. Und dann es gibt nur so zwei, drei, die wirklich Endkunden Zeug anbieten und die einen sind so halb Video-Streamer, halb Konsolenspiele-Streamer. Den Namen gerade vergessen. Es gibt auch einen Anbieter, der verdient quasi an so Amazon Instance-Images, also wozu dem Instance-Preis die nochmal einen Aufschlag für die Image pro Stunde draufschlagen. Aber so für PC-Gaming jetzt für Endkunden gibt es noch nicht so viel, die wirklich was zum Klicken haben. Es gibt einige, die sagen, ja, ja, bald und wir haben jetzt gerade Funding und so weiter. Aber die, die es wirklich anbieten, davon gibt es noch nicht so viele. Aber ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass das auf jeden Fall ein Markt werden könnte, der interessant ist. Aber das Problem ist dann halt eben, und dann kommen wir wieder auch zum Thema vielleicht Netzneutralität oder so, wenn dann halt deine Leitung gerade so ein bisschen gurgelt, dann bringt es das halt auch ganz schnell nicht mehr.
Weil ich denke mir jetzt gerade, mit so was wie dem neuen Apple TV kannst du ja im Prinzip alles spielen. Mit einem Controller und einem Bildschirm und dann sagst du halt einfach nur noch jetzt hier mit dieser Leistungs-Performance, das Game, lad mal, zack, ab geht er.
Und das Coole ist jetzt zum Beispiel dieser Steam. Also da war ich wirklich auch baff, wie cool Steam das integriert hat, weil das war wirklich, du musstest dich um fast nichts kümmern, um jetzt diesen Server und Client von Steam zusammenzubringen. Sobald das VPN steht, haben sich die beiden gefunden und sofort, also du siehst ja deine Steam-Library auf dem Mac und die Spiele, die nur für PC sind zum Beispiel, sind halt ausgegraut. So und in dem Moment, wo die sich sehen, steht sofort an diesem Spiel drin, Stream mit so einem Play-Button. Du klickst drauf und es geht einfach sofort los, der Sound kommt an, die Controls sind alle gemapped, also das ist wirklich, ich will fast sagen, eine One-Click-Experience und da war ich schon echt sehr erstaunt, wie gut das gemacht ist. Und klar, wenn, also, das einzige Problem ist halt nur, eben viele Leute haben wahrscheinlich einfach keine Internetverbindung, die gut genug ist. Dafür, also ich meine, ich hab jetzt halt Kabelmonat mit 100 Mbit, aber...
Was ist das immer für Messen, wie viel da so rüber kommt immer?
Also ich hab anderthalb Stunden gespielt, und dann haben wir 3,5 Gigabyte zumindest erstmal schon mal verbraten mit dem Stream. Das ist jetzt natürlich auch nicht so viel, aber...
Allerthalb Stunden sind 90 Minuten, ja. Mal 60 Sekunden sind... 0,6 Megabyte die Sekunde, also 650 Kilobyte die Sekunde, behauptet er jetzt, wenn ich mich nicht verrechnet hab. Von 3500 MB aus geht das eigentlich. Aber du hast wahrscheinlich öfter mal total Peaks drin und dafür... das ist ja nicht die ganze Zeit, 650. Okay, das heißt jemand, der nur 16 MB hat und nur 1,6 MB hat, kommt wahrscheinlich manchmal so an deine Limits, da dann ruckelt vielleicht ein bisschen.
Und vor allen Dingen, wenn du noch andere Leute im Haus hast und dann im Hintergrund noch dein iTunes-Update runterlädt und so weiter. Also das, ich weiß nicht, ob man dann den Kunden das so klar machen kann. Oder irgendwie, ich meine, ja. Aber ich könnte mir schon durchaus vorstellen, dass das ein zukunftsträchtiger Markt ist. Weil letztendlich Bock haben die Leute nicht, sich alle paar Nasen lang eine neue Konsole zu kaufen oder eine neue ein PC. Außer jetzt so Hardcore-Gamer. Aber ja, schauen wir mal. Wie gesagt, ich meine, ich konnte auch danach anderthalb Stunden nicht mehr spielen. Obwohl ich eine dicke Leitung tendenziell habe. Aber es hat dann halt geruckelt und dann war der Frust da. Und ich hab mir gedacht, fuck it. Ah, will weiterspielen. Aber ich wollte das mal zumindest hier erwähnt haben. Erwähnt haben, damit die Herrschaften da draußen vielleicht auch ein bisschen rum experimentieren können.
Wie weit bist du jetzt eigentlich bei der Human Resource-Maschine?
Nachdem ich dann angefangen hab, den ganzen Samstagvormittag an einem Level zu sitzen. Dann war es irgendwie um eins nachmittags. Da dachte ich mir, ah, scheiße, das ist mein Wochenende für ein fucking Puzzle. Muss ich noch mal gucken.
Ja, weil ich hab bis auf den allerletzten alle durchgezockt, außer den allerletzten Seitenstrang den auch noch nicht. Aber sonst ist das schon ganz witzig.
Hast du denn diese Challenge von Ralf Stockmann angenommen?
Welche?
Hier die Multiplikator-Challenge, wo er weniger Kommandos, weniger Steps als Optimum, also alles.
Ja, hab ich auch, glaube ich. Muss ich gucken, wie viel ich hab.
Okay, können wir nachher noch mal einen kleinen Schleifenvergleich machen, Schleifenlängenvergleich.
Ich hab aber einige Level, wo ich schneller bin als die Vorgabe.
Wer hat das hier auch? Ich hab's gepostet. Wer hat's gepostet?
Ist aber uralt.
Aber es wird ja geupdated. Ja, ich hab's noch nicht gekannt. Die Rede ist von dem Secure Messaging Scorecard von der EFF, wo alle möglichen Messenger mal nebeneinander verglichen werden, hinsichtlich ihrer Privacy-Features und Security-Features. Kannte ich noch nicht. Die gibt's halt scheinbar schon echt eine Weile. Und unten in den Fußnoten steht auch drin, dass sie das angeblich updaten. Natürlich ist es jetzt nicht total klar, wie diese Karte entstanden ist und wie sie das bewerten. Sie meinen halt, sie haben mit den Entwicklern geredet und mal nachgefragt. Ist halt jetzt die Frage, wie überprüfbar das dann wirklich ist für die proprietären Versionen. Aber es ist zumindest mal eine nette Übersicht, für die Leute, die Privacy und Security überhaupt interessiert.
Ja, mit ChangeLog, also man kann auch sehen, was sich dann geändert hat und warum, mit Links. Das sieht ganz ordentlich aus. Da passiert jetzt nicht unbedingt täglich was, aber der letzte Update ist aus Anfang November. Ja, ich pack mal den Link hier auch. Was liest man jetzt hier raus? Also genau genommen haben sie 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 Kategorien.
Genau.
Das erste ist Krypto in Transit, also ob sozusagen die eigentliche Kommunikation zwischen den Apps verschlüsselt stattfindet.
Das kriegen fast alle hin.
Es geht grundsätzlich um Chats, nicht um Krypto-Chats.
Facebook ist da auch dabei, glaube ich.
Ja, Secure Messaging.
Gibt es einen, der das nicht hat, das Häkchen da?
Ja, der Mxit. Oder Mxit. Was auch immer Mxit ist.
kick.com.
kick.com, das sind doch diese Klamotten-Laden.
Eine Grundvoraussetzung, oder?
Ja, also das ist sicherlich eine Grundvoraussetzung, die nicht unbedingt jetzt jeder hat, aber eigentlich alle. Dann ist die Krypto-Kommunikation, erfolgt die mit einem Schlüssel, den der Provider nicht hat. Da fällt schon mal so einiges raus. Also ist sozusagen das eine...
Aber Facetime und iMessage sind interessanterweise dabei. In der zweiten Spalte.
Ja, klar, weil, hat man ja auch glaube ich schon ein paar Mal, dass Apple explizit gesagt hat, deine Keys werden auf deinem Gerät erzeugt und liegen auch nur dort vor. Und wenn du halt irgendwie iMessage machst und du hast da mehrere Devices, dann muss halt jedes Device selber so einen Key mit generieren und dann kommen sozusagen weitere Keys mit dazu, die dann halt rangehängt werden. Das heißt, wenn du eine Nachricht erhältst, dann wird es eben für ein weiteres Device auch mit verschlüsselt. Aber es ist immer noch ein separater Key pro Gerät und nicht ein Key pro User, der halt irgendwie zentral liegt, sondern der liegt halt, naja, dezentral eben auf dem Gerät selber. Und da trennt sich schon so ein bisschen die Spreu vom Weizen. Also das ist schon erstaunlich. Dann haben sie als dritte Kategorie. Can you independently verify your correspondence identity? Also ob man sozusagen eine Möglichkeit hat, die Identität des Gegenübers festzustellen. Da dürfte dann wahrscheinlich Facetime und E-Message schon wieder rausfallen. Genau, das haben die nicht. Ja, wir können es jetzt noch mal ein bisschen komplettieren. Viertes Kriterium ist, gibt es sozusagen Forward Secrecy? Also wenn der Key in irgendeiner Form auftauchen sollte, ist dann sozusagen die Kommunikation, die früher gelaufen ist, sicher? Oder ist durch die Verschlüsselung sichergestellt, dass eben auch wenn ein Key auftaucht, alte Transaktionen nicht mehr entschlüsselt werden können? Das ist ja so ein klassisches GPG-Problem. Hast du einmal den Key und hast du einen Mitschnitt, dann kannst du halt auch alles nachteilig entschlüsseln. Während eben solche Systeme wie OTR ein anderes Verfahren eben explizit diese Forward Secrecy mit haben, indem sie halt immer wieder einen neuen Key berechnen, von Message zu Message, und dann geht das immer wieder so laufend so weiter, sodass du das eben nicht zurückführen kannst. Da wird es sehr unterschiedlich bei den einzelnen Anbietern, mal so, mal so. Also das hat beilabe nicht jeder.
Ja, vor allen Dingen diese ganzen GPGs fallen da raus.
Ja, genau. Und dann letzten drei Kriterien beziehen sich nicht mehr so auf die eigentliche Technik, sondern da ist halt nur der Code offen einsehbar, gibt es eine Doku für das Security-Design und gab es mal einen Code-Audit für das Ding. Also hat sich sozusagen mal dieses Unternehmen einem externen Überprüfung unterzogen, die nachvollziehbar ist und dann gibt es halt hier auch noch ein Häkchen. Ja, was gibt es dann? Was hat irgendwie alle Bullets? Man kann jetzt sogar streiten, ob man sozusagen alle braucht. Also ob alle sozusagen wirklich relevant sind. Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das so seht. Ich könnte natürlich sagen, mehr ist mehr.
Na ja, so ein Code-Audit, das ist schon mal keine schlechte Sache. Ist das Code Open to Independent Review? Das ist die Frage, was Independent Review ist und Open dafür.
Na ja, wenn jeder sagen kann, gib mal Source, ich will mal reingucken, dann ist das Open to Independent.
Ja, du musst schon irgendwie den Source-Code vorlegen. Ob der dann eben auch tatsächlich läuft, ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Aber zumindest gibt es einen Code, der den Anschein erweckt, dass er das sei. Interessant ist, dass auch iMessage hier so einen Audit-Check hat. Ich frage mich, von wem Apple sich da hat auditen lassen. Das gehört dann wohl doch schon zu guten Zonen. Und die einzigen komplett mit allen sieben Häckchen ausgestatteten Messenger sind so Sachen, die gar nicht so populär sind. Was haben wir hier? Chat-Secure und Orbot. Ist das Chat-Secure identisch mit dem Signal? Nee, das ist Text-Secure.
Off the Record Messaging for Windows. Pidgin, das Plugin oder wie?
Weiß ich nicht.
Und da das Signal oder Red Phone. Oh, und dann noch mehr. Silent Phone, Silent Text.
Und natürlich der Star, doch der Telegram, ne? Ach nee, stimmt gar nicht. Telegram ist gar nicht so gut. Ah doch, Telegram, Secret Chats. Telegram kann man auch als Secret Chat-Dingy benutzen.
Ach so, das gibt's echt. Mit offenen Source.
Wir sind ja alle so Streamer, nur das einzige Manko, was Streamer hat. Es hat eigentlich auch alles grün, außer der Code ist halt eben nicht open to independent review, weil die sind halt closed source, weil das ist halt ihr Business.
Na gut, also beziehungsweise es ist ihre Entscheidung, das so zu machen. Bei den anderen ist das auch ihr Business, aber wir haben halt trotzdem irgendwie Code offen.
Und WhatsApp hat nur zwei grüne Häkchen, und zwar bei Encrypted in Transit, und dass sie einen recent Code audited hätten. Aber okay, sie haben...
Das hat gar nichts darüber aus, was der Audit gebrannt hat, nur dass sie einen gehabt haben.
Also zum Beispiel nicht so Encrypted, dass die bei WhatsApp das nicht mehr mitlesen können.
Aber es ist schon erstaunlich, wie viele Systeme es überhaupt gibt.
Ja, und auch... ein bisschen überwältigend. Ich hätte ja gerne mal wieder so einen Meta-Messenger, der einfach so alles irgendwie wieder zusammenführt.
Das haben wir auch schon öfter überlegt.
Ich komm nicht mehr klar mit diesen ganzen Messenern. Und es ist auch so, die haben jetzt alle so ein scheiß, proprietäres Format, wo du halt nicht so einen Meta-Messenger machen kannst und auch sollst. Und dann haben auch viele keinen Desktop-Client. Und ich hab keinen Bock mehr darauf, wie auf diese Messenger-Lavine irgendwie. Also ich hab jetzt schon, ich hab diesen Facebook-Messenger, weil ich ja auch auf Facebook bin wegen Firma und überhaupt. Also ich bin irgendwie da Facebook. iMessage hab ich, ich hab Jabba, was ich selten benutze, aber ich hab's. Dann Threema. Dann hab ich auch so eine WhatsApp für Leute, die sonst irgendwie nicht zu erreichen sind. Also das sind schon vier. Und mich fragen trotzdem noch die ganze Zeit Leute, ja hier Telegram, bist du auch auf Telegram? Nee, ich will nicht noch ein Messenger. Wobei Telegram wenigstens ein Desktop-Client hat, muss man dazu sagen. Aber echt mir geht das alles jetzt mittlerweile mit diesem Messenger auf den Zünd da. Können sich nicht mal wieder alle auf einen einigen. So alle ICQ oder AIM, das war doch auch die goldene Zeit.
Ja, aber das ist auch wieder scheiße. Ich weiß ja nicht so recht.
Katzengoldene Zeit vielleicht.
Wenn der dann eine Security-Mack hat, dann hast du aber auch die Arschkarte. So gesehen ist das ja auch ein bisschen Dezentralisierung, dass es so viele gibt und das vielleicht ja auch gar nicht so schlecht. Dann bricht nicht gleich die ganze Welt zusammen, wenn da mal was schief geht. Da wird was schief gehen. Und ist auch schon.
Ja, es war halt so eine schöne Utopie, dieses Jabber, weil irgendwie hast du halt deine eigenen Gateways und Server, die alle trotzdem irgendwie miteinander reden können, mit so einem schönen Lazy-Connection-Verhalten. Also wenn du jetzt das erste Mal mit irgendeinem anderen Jobber-Server sprichst, dann wird halt da eben mal so eine Verbindung zu dem Server aufgemacht. Und man kann das alles dezentralisieren und so weiter. Und nur weil der eine Server unsicher ist und schlechte Protokolle benutzt, muss das nicht heißen, dass alles andere unsicher ist. Du kannst noch sowas wie OTR oben drauf machen. Es gibt Clients für alle Plattformen in jeder Form und Farbe. Alles quasi offen. Du kannst deine eigenen Clients sogar dafür programmieren. Aber trotz all dem hat es sich dann am Ende zu nerdy oder zu frickel. Ich weiß gar nicht, was. So Jabba oder dieses XMPB, vielleicht diese komplizierte Abkürzung.
Es sind mehrere Sachen, die, glaube ich, Jabba den Todesstoß gegeben haben. Also es war zwar an sich eine interessante Vision, so einen Standard zu schaffen.
Na, hat ja auch vergleichsweise lange gut funktioniert.
Ja, aber es war einfach bei Design für die modernen Anforderungen nicht geeignet.
Die modernen Anforderungen?
Naja, also zunächst einmal hieß ja Jabba, du warst ein Client, der die ganze Zeit eine Verbindung hält.
Ach so, mit Notifications und so weiter auf dem Mobil Device und da alles.
Ja, dann musste die ganze Zeit eine TCP-Verbindung, das ist halt einfach nur für Mobile und Batterieschonung ist das einfach nicht gedacht. Und man hat das ja gesehen, die ersten Jabba Clients, die es ja dann auch tatsächlich gab auf iOS, die dann halt mit Ach und Krach, dann mit iOS 3 oder 4 in der Lage waren im Hintergrund, irgendwie so eine Background-Connection zu halten, aber das ist halt einfach alles nicht sonderlich effizient. Dann das zweite Problem ist, dass bei Jabba eben auch grundsätzlich eben keine, so Multi-Client war da nicht wirklich Teil des Konzepts. Das ging irgendwie schon auch so.
In Presence Notification oder so was, oder wie?
Nein, dass du einfach einen zweiten Client auch connectest und der dann sozusagen die fehlenden Nachrichten bekommt. Du kriegst ja immer nur die Nachrichten, die ankommen in dem Moment, wo du verbunden bist. Bist du dann nicht verbunden, kriegst du die Nachrichten nicht. Ja klar, und dann kannst du aber dann natürlich deinen Server auch so konfigurieren, dass er Nachrichten erstmal vorhält, aber wenn der erste Client die abgeholt hat, dann sind die halt auch weg und verschlüsselt sind sie dann auch nicht. Da fehlte einfach zu dem, was wir heute einfach als gegeben ansehen. Bis hin zu eben jetzt auch diesen neuen Krypto-Fragen mit per device oder per client, Krypto-Key und so weiter. Das war ja alles überhaupt nicht vorgesehen.
Deswegen sag ich ja auch schöne Utopie.
Schöne Utopie und im Prinzip auch sehr schade, dass das an der Stelle das eben auch nicht gereicht hat. Ich meine, das ist aber auch so ein Ding, muss man auch sagen, im Netz mit Open Source und offenen Protokollen. Das ist zwar manchmal seiner Zeit voraus, weil dann eben, da wird dann sehr früh ein Bedarf gesehen. Und ich meine, Chat, das geht ja zurück bis IRC. Also das gab's schon mit einer illustren Bandbreite mit Server, Netzwerken, Pipapo, tausend Commando-Zahlen und Optionen, was du da alles kicken und bennen und administrieren und so und so. Das ist ja mega mächtig. Und das war relativ früh da, aber halt auch ohne nennenswerte Level von Security, ohne nennenswerte Level von Reliability und Failover, mit diesem ganzen Netzplitz und diesem ganzen Kram. Das hat man dann so hingenommen und das nimmt man halt bis heute so hin, weil ist so. Aber der Druck, dann auch mal was Neues zu machen und wirklich davon wegzukommen, der war halt relativ gering. Java war dann so ein Schritt IRC, hat man halt gesehen, so ah ja Instant Messaging, ICQ, AEM hat so den Weg gezeigt, so ein bisschen. Brauchen wir irgendwie auch. War dann auch total geil, als es da war. Sah dann auch für eine Zeit sehr gut aus, als Facebook und Google das auch gemacht haben, so. Weil das war sozusagen das, was man erstmal so, was man erstmal so implementiert hat, weil war ja schon irgendwas da, kann man sich mit anderen Netzwerken verbinden, bis sie dann halt alle drauf gekommen sind. Warte mal, Messenger sind einfach mal die geile Login-Nummer überhaupt. Wenn du deinen Messenger attraktiv machst, dann kannst du dir mit Features vollknallen, wo dann halt so ein XMPP auch nicht mehr mitzieht. Du hast dann neue Anforderungen und wart mal auf so ein XMPP-Konsortium, bis es dann hinterher nicht stattfindet. Es ist ein Wunder, dass das Web mit HTML irgendwie noch so halbwegs Schritt halten kann. Da ist einfach, sagen wir mal, der Bedarf und die Wichtigkeit dieses Subsystems, die ist so groß, dass es da irgendwie noch funktioniert, auch wenn es ja immer wieder so Trends in die andere Richtung gibt, mit Flash hat sich lang gehalten und all diese ganzen Subsysteme. Stimmt. Das ist so, und ich denke, der Zug ist jetzt auch irgendwie abgefahren durch diese gnadenlose Verplattformung des Netzes. Also eigentlich muss ich sagen, ist jetzt auch gerade hier von dem Konrad Lischka ein interessanter Text so als E-Pub, E-Book veröffentlicht worden, hab den noch nicht ganz zu Ende gelesen, aber es ist sehr interessant, wo er das auch alles mal zusammen analysiert und so ein paar Thesen aufstellt und im Kern sagt er halt auch, es ist 2015 ist eigentlich das totale Horror-Jahr, weil man einfach jetzt mehr denn je sieht, wie wir da unter dem, unter dieser Verplattformung des Netzes leiden und im Prinzip die Leute immer weiter wegkommen von dieser Idee des offenen Netzes. Das ist etwas, was wir seit Ewigkeiten irgendwie leben und immer gespürt haben und als wichtig erachten. Aber klick mal auf YouTube und dann siehst du halt schon die Umfragen, dass die Leute meinen, so ne Internet mach ich ja eigentlich gar nicht. Ich bin ja auf Facebook.
Ja, ich mach ja wie gesagt, ich hab ja auch da immer so diese Studenten, die ich das Internet erkläre.
Ja, weil die wissen glaube ich zumindest noch, dass Facebook ein Dienst im Internet ist.
Ja, also da gibt es auch so Kandidaten, wo man so denkt. Also ich stelle immer die Frage, wer von euch weiß denn, was der Unterschied zwischen dem World Wide Web und dem Internet ist? Da geht also selten mal überhaupt ein Arm hoch.
Wirklich?
Ja, immer noch. Deswegen war diesen Kurs auch immer noch weiter. Bis da der Erste sitzt, der weiß, was ein Cookie ist und weiß, dass das Internet das Rohr ist, wo man Gas, Wasser, Nutella oder Katzenfotos durchjagen kann und... Das BWW, eine der Sachen ist die durchs Rohr gejagt werden, aber und so weiter. Aber ja, das ist überhaupt, also wir leben ja sowieso in unserer kleinen Nerdbubble und denken halt, naja, also mittlerweile, jetzt weiß man noch was in etwa, was da so abgeht, aber es ist nicht so, also ganz und gar nicht leider. Und ich mein, heute hat sich auch einer hier wieder auf Twitter beschwert, so dass man jetzt hier, also wieder die GEMA, ist ja immer noch so ein Problem und man braucht jetzt einen VPN und wenn das VPN die Antwort ist, um jetzt an Content zu kommen, dann ist das Internet kaputt. Dann meine ich auch, naja, es ist halt auch so, diese Content, ich sage jetzt nicht Mafia, sondern Contentindustrie, die das halt forciert und natürlich auch die Konsumer, die das ja dann auch so wollen oder abnehmen. Und ja, ich meine, am Anfang vom Internet und vom WWW, da war halt alles unkompromittiert. Also es war einfach, da waren keine Kompromisse, weil halt auch wenig Nutzer da waren und die Anwendungsfälle gering. Und je mehr Leute Interesse haben, irgendwas im Internet zu machen, desto mehr Kompromisse und desto mehr so Cluster-Bildung gibt es dann halt. Das kann man glaube ich auch einfach nichts machen. Da kann man auch reden und meckern, wie man will. Ich glaube, das wird jetzt erstmal so weiter gehen. Ich hoffe nur, dass auch für die Leute, die das Internet noch anders zu benutzen wissen, dass das auch weiterhin noch geht und dass nicht dann auch irgendwie durch diese komplette Inselbildung irgendwann unmöglich wird und das Internet einfach nur noch so nicht mehr so ein Massenmedium ist, wo jeder reinschreiben kann, sondern...
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht so richtig, was wir jetzt tun sollen. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob man überhaupt noch irgendwas tun kann.
Na, was wir tun können, ist die Leute aufklären. Das ist ja hier quasi oberster Freak Show-Auftrag eh. Das ist nicht erdig. Und Aufklärung betreiben und dann, was die Leute draus machen, das haben wir dann nicht mehr. Also haben wir auch noch, weil wir können natürlich so ein bisschen die Gehirne manipulieren und mit unseren sonoren Radiostimmen langsam die Wahrheit in ihre Köpfe bringen.
Netzneutralität, Netzneutralität, Netzneutralität.
Aber ja.
Ja gut, aber trotzdem können wir die Geschicke auch... Ich meine, wir sind ja auch selber Opfer. Ich meine, das ist ja immer diese ewige Debatte, sind wir nun Fanboys oder nicht? Und bewegen wir uns alle schon unter Steves Knute und haben jeden Bezug zur Welt verloren. So, nee, es ist halt schwierig, weil du musst halt auch immer abwägen zwischen was ist so die reine Lehre und was wäre eigentlich geil, aber was lässt sich aber auch vielleicht überhaupt nicht ohne weiteres erzielen. Also gerade jetzt dieses Beispiel mit einem Standard für Internetkommunikation, was halt sowohl schon mal daran scheitert, dass du eben auf der einen Seite immer neue Features haben willst, du willst dich schnell weiterentwickeln, neue Märkte anpassen, neue Nutzungsanforderungen und so weiter, aber bist du da auf so einem Konsortium, warte zu ewig. Plus, dass man eben auch nicht unbedingt einen Vorteil davon hat, weil man will ja seine Plattform sozusagen auch irgendwie, die die Leute bei sich behalten in einem kapitalistischen System. Und da sind natürlich jetzt Features, die jetzt vor allem erstmal einen Exit leichter machen. Ja, oder das sich aufhalten in einer anderen Plattform. Eigentlich nicht so geil, zumal du ja natürlich auch in so einer Schnittstelle nach außen auch sofort auch wieder dieses Standardisierungsproblem hast. Du musst ja dann sozusagen Legacy Support machen für die machen das irgendwie anders oder da gibt es dieses Feature nicht oder die haben irgendwas, was wir nicht haben und das muss dann irgendwie wieder übersetzt werden. Dass das im Telefonnetz so lange funktioniert hat, ist ja eigentlich ein Wunder.
Zwei Drähte waren ein bisschen analog.
Ja, zwei Drähte analog, aber gut man kann sagen mit dem ISDN-System ist es dann auch schon so ein bisschen auseinander gegangen. Andererseits ist es beim Mobilfunk.
Das war ja außerhalb von Europa. War ja ISDN ja auch nie irgendwie groß.
Na, Ami ist der Inhalt, Mobilfunk.
Und dann machen die Amis ihr CDMA oder wie das da heißt.
Ja gut, aber im Interconnect war das dann sozusagen, du kannst eine SMS weltweit verschicken, andere Dinge und du hast ein internationales Billing. Also die haben natürlich auch ihr Problem, dass sie eigentlich keine Security in ihrem System haben.
Sie haben das nicht, um es schweineteuer, aufs Megabyte gerechnet teurer, als wenn du zur ISS was haben willst.
Was, jetzt eine SMS? Ja gut, das ist noch mal ein anderes Problem. Ich rede ja jetzt nur von dieser Kompatibilität zueinander. Willst du sozusagen ein durch offenes, standardsgetriebenes Netz haben und man kann über das Telefonnetz schimpfen, wie man will. Das ist im Wesentlichen ein auf standardsbasierende Telekommunikation. Und das ist im Internet natürlich auch, was die Basiskommunikation betrifft, auch wenn, wie du schon richtig angesprochen hast, jetzt durch die mangelnde Netzneutralität dieses Gebäude auch langsam ins Wanken kommt. Aber auf dem Application-Layer, da ist halt schwierig. Und da entscheiden sich aber die Spieler und die Strategien und die Player und die die neuen Mächte werden eben an der Stelle definiert. Und keiner hat das halt so gut hinbekommen wie wie Facebook. Ein paar andere haben es auch noch hinbekommen.
Ja, Google hat es schon auch.
Ja, aber nicht so gut wie Facebook. Ich meine, Facebook hat im Prinzip das Potenzial, so ziemlich alles, was im Netz irgendwie relevant ist, da einzubauen jetzt. Die können da Payment einbauen, eine ganze Video-Geschichte. Also alles, was die anderen Plattformen groß macht, könnten sie da im Prinzip auch rein machen. Video, was da mittlerweile schon an Video gesurft und gepostet wird innerhalb von YouTube, ich weiß nicht, das kann wahrscheinlich rein zahlenmäßig mit YouTube noch nicht mithalten, ist aber definitiv auch schon extrem groß und definitiv auch growing und so wie eben Facebook aufgebaut ist, dass die Leute ja teilweise da gar nicht mehr rauskommen. Du merkst ja auch, und wie perfide das auch ist so, ja also auf Twitter, dann wird da so ein Video gepostet, dann willst du da irgendwie einen Link drauf generieren, aber alles was du irgendwie generieren kannst, ist nur noch ein Link auf diesen gesamten Posting-Kontext, so dass du dann auch immer wieder in diese Webseiten-Welten landest, bei Facebook ist das ähnlich. Also es ist immer so ein komm zu mir, komm zu mir, komm zu mir, weg von diesen rohen Datenformaten, aber es ist halt auch verständlich, weil das rohe, nackte Internet ist halt auch einfach mal ein garstiger Ort. Und da muss man also wirklich schon eine Lizenz, ja, muss man irgendwie schon so eine Schwertlizenz haben.
Ja, und selbst wenn man die hat, sieht es dann immer noch aus wie Pfefe.
Sieht was aus wie Pfefe?
Das nackte, rohe Internet.
Die Bilder kriege ich jetzt nicht aus meinem Kopf.
Nein, seine Seite, nicht er selbst.
Naja, also ja, genau, alles schwierig. Ich finde es auch gerade deshalb hier in diesem Podcast immer wieder schön, weil hier wir uns immer dann versammeln und uns in unserer kleinen Bubble noch daran erinnern, gemeinsam, dass es nicht nur alles klicky-bunt ist und irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr dahinter steckt. Aber das ist wirklich mit den Studenten zum Beispiel auch immer wieder krass, weil letztendlich benutzen die das Netz jeden Tag. Jeden Tag, meistens sogar noch während des Unterrichts sozusagen, die schlagen Sachen in der Wikipedia nach und nehmen alles auch als total Gott gegeben an und wissen einfach null, wie es funktioniert. Und ich finde halt immer gerade so bei so, da haben wir mal ein Massenmedium, in das jeder reinschreiben kann. Das ist ja für mich eigentlich sowieso mit das krasseste Feature an diesem Internet, weil davor gab es einfach nie irgendein Massenmedium, wo man, selbst wenn jeder hätte reinschreiben können, es nicht auf der ganzen Welt gleichzeitig auch konsumiert hätte werden können, sozusagen. Und wenn man halt überhaupt null Ahnung hat, wie sozusagen das Ganze funktioniert, dann nutzt einem der Fakt, dass man da reinschreiben kann, auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel, wenn man dann halt irgendwie so den geilsten Teil vielleicht vom Medium verpasst sogar und halt nur auf diese Insel vorgefertigte Schablone hier so funktioniert, Internet halt reduziert ist.
Tja, also gerade Wikipedia ist ein gutes Beispiel, weil viele Leute einfach überhaupt nicht verstehen, wie Wikipedia auch überhaupt entsteht. Ja, genau. Das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt hier in unserem Hörerkreis kein Thema, aber außerhalb dieses Hörerkreises sehr wohl. Und ich bin ja auch so ein bisschen ratlos. Also was ich ja noch gar nicht erwähnt hatte, wir hatten ja hier nach der letzten Sendung, am Wochenende haben wir ja hier unseren Podcast-Workshop gehabt und da war das halt dann auch ein Thema. Ich habe das dann auch in meinem Talk, habe ich das auch erwähnt und angesprochen. Zumindest auch alles online, auf YouTube kann ich gleich nochmal verlinken, die ganzen Talks vom Podcast-Workshop, dass eigentlich A, die Podcast-Landschaft eigentlich die gefühlt mitletzte, technisch noch unabhängige, sich weitgehend in den alten Web-Standards bewegende Medienlandschaft ist und dass ich halt auch diesen Hype, der jetzt eben gerade so um die Ecke kommt, der zweite Hype, der erste ist immer ungefällig, aber der zweite ist schwierig, so und jetzt sind wir halt beim zweiten, dass ich den schon so mit einigerm, wie soll ich sagen, mit einem gewissen Unwohlsein zur Kenntnis nehme. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite ist es schön, ja, Geld, Investitionen, bla, mehr Leute können davon leben, alles super und in Ordnung, aber dann kommt halt jetzt Google daher, das hat man ja glaube ich in der letzten Sendung auch schon angesprochen oder vorletzt schon und sagt so, ja, wir spielen da jetzt auch mal mit und wenn wir sehen, was dabei herauskommt und irgendwann wird es dann eben auch nur noch so in zwei, drei Unternehmen ausgemacht, was Podcasting ist oder sein kann oder es wird halt sein gelassen, kriegt aber neue Barrieren, weil sich natürlich jetzt andere Radioformate in gewisser Hinsicht denn auch schneller und intelligenter entwickeln können. Also sagen wir mal, sehe ich jetzt nicht unbedingt so unmittelbar am Horizont, aber nur mal so als Gedankenspiel. Facebook hätte jetzt, also Podcasting wird jetzt einfach mal noch populärer, es gibt noch mal so zwei, drei Sachen, wo alle so, ja, Podcasting gibt's mir und alle können sich nichts Schöneres mehr vorstellen als morgens unter der Dusche schon mit ihrem wassergestellten iPhone sich Podcasts reinzuhauen, so und das müsste jetzt irgendwie bedient werden. So, dann wäre das vielleicht irgendwann Teil von Facebook, wo du dann so in der Facebook-App auch noch sozusagen dieses Feature mit drin hast, dass du so Radiosendungen abonnieren kannst und dann wird das einfach Teil dieser Facebook-App. Und dann kommen da auch geile Features, weil dann können sie da auch alles machen, weil sie sich ja nur innerhalb ihres eigenen Ökosystems bewegen. Ja, dann wird das mit irgendwie Radio-Streaming verheiratet.
Und dann Promote your Podcast-Episode, sonst kriegen es nicht alle gleichzeitig in die Timeline.
Und Like-Buttons und Werbung, Einblenden und das volle Programm. Also wäre ja alles denkbar und kann auch kommen. Ich hoffe, es bleibt uns erst mal ein bisschen erspart, aber es wäre dann auch nicht zu optimistisch. So und dann popularisiert sich das eben durch diesen Netzwerkeffekt, den Facebook einfach schon hat und der nicht unerheblich ist. Ja und dann stehen wir Podcast-er halt da mit dem Schild, so wir müssen leider draußen bleiben. Aber wir sind ja frei! Genau, diese Sendung heißt nicht ohne Grund so. Ja, genug gejammert.
Ich will mal wieder grätschen und zwar sag mal Hucke, weil der Timme muss eh da ein bisschen regeln und so und seine Listen sortieren. Du hast doch mal erzählt, du wolltest doch mal so einen Mailserver aufsetzen, so mit Krypto und so oder?
Ja, hab ich auch gemacht, ja.
Woher weißt du denn davon nichts?
Hab ich bestimmt schon mal erzählt.
Nee, hast du immer gesagt, du willst das mal machen.
Kann man sich bei der anmelden für Mail, theoretisch.
Also, stopp, Moment. Stopp. Um es mal anders zu sagen, du hast mal gesagt, du wolltest das mal wirklich so, damit Leute, die sich halt nicht darum kümmern können, weil nicht alle irgendwie so Vollblut-Nerds sind, irgendwie da so ein einigermaßen sicher E-Mail kriegen. Du hast das nur wirklich für Friends und Family gemacht und nicht für alle. Aber du wolltest das eigentlich für alle machen, oder?
Ich hab mal drüber nachgedacht, ob man so ein kleines Angebot mal macht. Und ich hätte das auch nur so gemacht, für eine limitierte Userzahl. Also ich hätte das jetzt nicht beliebig skalieren wollen. Einfach weil dann ist auch deine Verantwortung so, als dass du nicht so groß bist.
Bei Pausen musst du eh aufhören, weil sonst können sie mir dir mit den... Also du musst dann die abschnäufigen Maßnahmen unterstützen.
Genau. Und dann hab ich da halt noch so ein paar Mal drüber geschlafen. Dann dachte ich mir, ich hab nicht die Zeit, mich dann auch um die ganzen User zu kümmern und deren Fragen und Wünsche und so weiter und so fort. Und dachte mir, also ich würd's gerne machen, aber ich kann das eigentlich nicht so leisten. Und deswegen hab ich das dann halt wirklich nur so für kleinen Kreis gemacht. Also dich würde ich da schon rauflassen.
Ich hab meinen eigenen, so ist es nicht. Wir können dann nach der Sendung noch mal drüber reden.
Aber eine Mail-Server aufsetzen, hat man eh schon ein paar Mal. Das ist so, wie du gerade meintest. Also wenn man dann mal so hinter das nackte, mitteilende Internet guckt.
Ja, das ist eigentlich nicht schwer, aber Moos ist schon einmal, Moos einmal alles richtig machen. Und weil man vielleicht auch nur denkt, dass man alles richtig gemacht hat, sollte man vielleicht auch noch einmal einen drüber gucken lassen, der zumindest auch das Gleiche denken sollte.
Wir haben das glaube ich schon vor einer Weile mal sagen, nicht einfach irgendeinem Tutorial blind hinterher, copy and paste ins Terminal, weil dann habt ihr nicht so viel gewonnen. Und zum Beispiel hier diese Anleitung vorhin mit diesem Windows 10 auf der externen Platte. Da sind, wie gesagt, auf Windows 7.1 oder 7, was ich hatte, da waren die Commands halt so ein bisschen anders und dann muss man auch da wieder so ein bisschen frickeln. Also ja, ich weiß nicht, also man muss halt auch, man muss schon für eigenen Mailserver oder für solche Sachen immer so ein bisschen Hacker-Spirit haben und einfach auch wildend sein, mal wenn es nicht gerade so eine One-Button-Click-Option gibt, einfach auch mal selber ein bisschen zu frickeln und zu gucken. Das ist halt alles immer nicht so einfach dann. Und Mailserver und wie gesagt, sage ich auch mal den Studenten zum Beispiel, die fragen ja dann immer, ja, wenn ich ihr Paranoial-Level so ein bisschen angehoben habe, so von wegen mit, wer trackt euch wie, wann und wo und dann so, ja, was können wir denn jetzt tun, um uns davor zu schützen? Dann muss ich leider auch meistens sagen, ja, jetzt auch nicht so viel, weil wenn ihr halt Sicherheit wollt, dann gibt es nicht diese einen Button, macht alles sicher, automatisch und ihr müsst nicht darüber nachdenken, weil das ist dann per Definition einfach nicht sicher, wenn ihr nicht wisst, wie es funktioniert, wenn ihr nicht reingucken könnt, wenn ihr es nicht versteht, ja.
Und Sicherheit ist ja auch eher eine sehr dynamische Sache, weil was heute sicher war, ist in nächster Woche vielleicht schon nicht mehr sicher, und da muss man halt nachpatchen, andere Krypto-Algorithmen benutzen und man muss sich halt ja andauernd anpassen und schon auch ein Race of Arms, oder nennt man das?
Ja, also ich würde sagen, vor allen Dingen ist es halt Arbeit, also ich meine ich treibe ja auch seit eh und je meinen eigenen Server und schon alleine so den Server immer auf dem neuesten Stand zu halten und immer zu gucken und zu updaten und Probleme zu fixen, damit machst du halt auch so ein bisschen Zeit, locker tut das, macht ja auch Spaß, deswegen machen wir es ja auch, aber das ist jetzt auch nicht nur Spaß und ja das führt ja dann auch, was wir jetzt gerade gesagt haben, dieser Inselbildung und so weiter, das sind ja halt dann am Ende auch genau vor allen Dingen die Leute, die eben diese Ein-Button-Click-Lösung wollen und jetzt halt nicht den Nerv haben, sich mit irgendwelchen Tutorials rumzuschlagen und dann die Lösung noch mal ein bisschen zu optimieren. Also es haben ja auch viele schon gefragt hier so, kannst du mal ein Tutorial zum Mail-Server posten? Habe ich ja dann auch irgendwie gesagt eigentlich tatsächlich lieber nicht, weil ich halt nicht will, dass man einfach nur so ein Tutorial nachklickt und dann denkt man hat es dann so, sondern dann muss man selber durch.
Wenn man das alles erklären würde, was man da wie einstellen muss, dann würde das auch ein ganz schön langes Tutorial werden. Weil einfach nur so was nehmen geht glaube ich nicht.
Judi, jetzt Tim, du hast noch Listen sortiert vielleicht in der Zwischenzeit und kannst das nächste Thema anmoderieren.
Ja, die Themen kommen vor euch diesmal. Ich bin ein bisschen...
Ist doch gut.
Ich bin so ein bisschen...
Out of Thema.
Out of Thema, genau. Also, ich könnte aber noch was einschmeißen. Einen hab ich noch. Wie newsworthy das ist, aber da ja WordPress durchaus verbreitet ist, und ich das ja auch selber verwende, mag das nochmal ganz interessant sein. Und zwar hat Matt Mullenweg, der Ur-Developer von WordPress und Chef von diesem Auto-Matic, die halt auch wordpress.com machen, immer sehr viel von diesem ganzen Development übersehen. Die haben jetzt eine Desktop-Admin-App rausgebracht für WordPress. Und das ist insofern sehr interessant, als dass das, sozusagen abgesehen jetzt von dieser iOS-App, die es auch gab, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es für Android auch eine Version gab, aber es gab auch für iOS, gab es so eine Admin-Geschichte, das funktionierte aber eher so schlecht als recht, weil WordPress in dem Sinne überhaupt gar keine API hatte. Und das hat sich halt jetzt seit dem letzten WordPress 4.3, glaube ich, jetzt mit 4.3 und 4.4, ändert sich das sozusagen schrittweise mit so einem API definiert. Und ja, das ermöglicht jetzt ganz andere Sachen, wie zum Beispiel diese neue App, die jetzt, glaube ich, unter dem Codenamen Calypso irgendwie läuft und unter desktop.wordpress.com ist. Dann kannst du halt jetzt so eine App runterladen und das passiert alles jetzt irgendwie auf Node.js, Java, Skript und so, und du atmest schwer.
Also von allen Technologien, aber gut.
Was hast du erwartet? Also ich meine, das ist jetzt sozusagen... Zukunft. Das ist jetzt sozusagen der Weg weg von PHP, ne?
Ja, aber das ist ja... Ja, nee, nee, das ist irgendwie zu... Nee, das ist wieder mal der feuchte Traum, einer der feuchten Träume der Computergeschichte. Wir schreiben den Code nur einmal und es läuft überall. Und was machen sie? Sie machen am Ende einen glorifizierten Webview und verkaufen das als App quasi, ne?
Kann schon sein.
Also es ist halt nicht wirklich eine App-App. So ähnlich wie Slack halt. So wir packen das in so einen App-Bundle, aber am Ende ist es halt Web eigentlich auch.
Was in Ordnung ist, also ich meine, wenn alle Web-Apps so funktionieren würden wie die von Slack, dann bin ich sold. Also ich meine dann...
Ich nicht, weil diese Slack-App, also sorry, aber du, gerade du als UI, sagen wir mal, so strenger UI-Benutzer, du wirst auch, du würdest mir jetzt nicht erzählen, dass jetzt diese Slack-App sich jetzt nach allen, also Steve-gegebenen, UI-Paradigmen verhält und irgendwie alles richtig macht. Also wenn du mir das jetzt erzählst, dann ist alles, was ich von dir kenne und alle Rahns, die du jemals von dir gegeben hast, zu UI und Interfaces und wie sich so eine native Abzuverhalten hat, das ist ja dann invalidiert, weil diese Slack-App, die verhält sich ja nach wie vor ganz klar wie so eine Container-App. Also in fast allen Aspekten. Die ist ja nicht mal mit Talent beim Klicken. Also ich stimme dir zu, dass bei so Sachen wie Text-Selection, ja eine Sache zum Beispiel, oder Window-Resize, oder App-Start und Initialisierung, oder Preferences, oder Kontext-Menüs teilweise, also da sind so viele Fnords drin, die halt weit weg von einer nativen App sind.
Okay, widerspreche ich dir auch nicht, trotzdem muss ich feststellen, ist das im Vergleich zu diesen Verbrechen, die so die Java-Welt auf dem Desktop mit sich gebracht hat? Ist auch geschenkt, darüber sage ich eigentlich gar nichts, was ja hier sozusagen stattfindet ist, sie haben sich ein API besorgt. Sie fangen an sozusagen dieses WordPress jetzt auch selber über ein API zu definieren und ihr Ansatz ist jetzt eine Admin-App zu machen, man kann aber natürlich über dieses API jetzt auch ganz andere Anwendungen denken. Und das könnte ganz interessant sein, so oder so, wer also WordPress-Sites verwaltet und Bock hat auf so ein Admin-Interface, sollte sich vielleicht einfach mal diese Desktop-App anschauen, die ist auf jeden Fall ganz interessant, wenn man halt so seinen Kram auf wordpress.com hat, dann bietet sich das ohnehin an und man kann hintenrum, wenn man über wordpress.com sich einloggt, quasi, also wenn man sozusagen seine Webseiten zur Administration über wordpress.com freigeschaltet hat, dann kann man die halt hier auch haben. Das heißt, ich habe hier mehr oder weniger so ein Single-Sign-On und sehe halt irgendwie alle meine Sites.
Aber das geht dann nur über wordpress.com?
Das geht dann über wordpress.com, aber ich glaube, du kannst es auch diese App direkt so benutzen, um deinen Blog zu machen, aber dann musst du es wahrscheinlich die neuste Version von der abjabben.
Aber du kannst nicht mehrere WordPress-Sites da mit deinen individuellen Accounts sozusagen konfigurieren und dann zwischenhin und her schalten?
Ich denke, dass das schon geht.
Also, spuck mir das mal an.
Das ist jetzt noch nicht ganz...
Weil prinzipiell ist das Konzept natürlich super. Ich habe nämlich auch einige WordPress-Installationen irgendwo am Laufen und so und so ein zentrales Tool zum Management als Idee finde ich natürlich nicht verkehrt. Aber ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt so super scharf drauf sein, dass ich mir dann dafür so ein WordPress-Login vielleicht noch dann ans Bein binden muss. Wobei ich den wahrscheinlich eh habe für Gravatar und so.
Sehe ich das richtig? Die gibt es nur für OS X?
Ja, die gibt es bisher nur für OS X. Wird aber auch für andere Apps kommen, für andere OS gekommen. Also Windows.
Auf Windows wird nicht geblockt.
Naja, ich meine, kannst du dir denken, was die Leute, was deren Home-OS ist?
Ja, das ist ja jetzt offensichtlich. Es hat mich trotzdem gewundert.
Aber bist du sicher, dass die nicht so einen User-Agent-Check haben und dir einfach nur den OS X Download anbieten?
Deswegen habe ich gefragt.
Also in der Blog-Welt war das doch so einer der ersten Durchbrüche für OS X damals.
Naja, egal wie auch immer. Also ich meine eigentlich sollte so eine Node.js-App auch wunderbar woanders laufen.
Wie und das ist jetzt ein Node.js in einer Web-View oder irgendwie gebundelt oder der macht da hintenrum Sockets auf und unterhält sich mit sich selbst? Oder wie muss man sich das jetzt vorstellen?
Ich verweigere klare Aussagen und sage, dieser Code auf den du rumklickst ist mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit zu 100% Javascript, der da irgendwie gerade sich vor dir abspult. Und da steckt dann auch noch React mit drin. Also das ist sozusagen eine React-Slash-Nodes-React-App.
Ich meine, du musst es ja nicht programmieren, also das ist ja gut.
Sie haben jetzt PHP damit ausgetauscht.
Nein, nein, das war auch so eine große Missverständnisnummer, da haben wir aufgepasst.
Nein, WordPress selber ist noch in PHP, das ist mir schon klar. Nur sehen Sie das jetzt als den nächsten Schritt in Richtung Zukunft?
Ja, das sehen Sie schon.
Alles in Javascript zu machen?
Ich glaube, Sie haben jetzt noch keine Aussage gemacht im Hinblick auf alles, aber Sie haben gesagt, Sie hätten sich hingesetzt und gesagt, was, wenn wir kein Legacy hätten, was würden wir dann tun?
Neues Legacy nehmen.
Welches neues Legacy meinst du denn jetzt? Ja, gut, ich meine, das ist auf jeden Fall ein extrem skalierendes Environment, wo eine Menge geschieht. Also jetzt können wir natürlich da mit Programmiersprachen, Heiligkeit rangehen, dann werden wir nicht viel Erfolg haben, aber da tut sich halt viel im Web so. Ich meine, es ist einfach mal auf jeden Fall besser auf dem Kleint als PHP.
Ja, ich meine, letztendlich würde es dich interessieren, wenn die Oberfläche genauso aussieht. Auch nicht.
Also, ich meine, wie gesagt, es ist halt einfach deutlich responsiver, was ich hier abspielen kann mit diesem Kleinten.
Ja, aber wenn das PHP auf deiner Maschine laufen würde, ohne ein Request auf einem anderen Server, dann wäre das genauso snappy. Also, PHP ist ja jetzt nicht so schnarchend langsam, als wenn du das lokal ausführen würdest. Also, du kriegst ja höchstwahrscheinlich ein gebandeltes Node.js, wo jetzt dieser Webview gerendert wird und das alles lokal quasi ausgeliefert wird. Insofern, wenn da ein PHP-Interpreter, den du eh auf deinem Mac hast, das lokal ausführen würde, wäre das auch rattenschnell.
Aber ich bin nicht so sicher. PHP, das ist diese Sprache, wo irgendwie erstmal der gesamte Code neu gepasst wird, in dem Moment, wo er angeklickt wird. Ich bitte dich.
Das ist mit vier Kernen heutzutage und alles drum und dran, ist auch schnell.
48.
48, Armkurs.
Ich zieh das Thema wieder zurück.
Nee, ist ja okay. Also die Idee, so eine App zu machen, weil ist jetzt fast so wie mit Endgeräten. Der Trend geht jetzt zum Drittblock. Also wer nur noch eins hat, ist ja schon total hinten dran. Und insofern macht das durchaus Sinn, so eine Management-App zu haben.
Oh Mist, ich hab nur zwei.
So Dennis.
Ich schon wieder, ja.
Guck mal was draus hier.
Super. Ähm, ja, ist auch nur eine kleine Geschichte eigentlich. Also ich hab ja zu Hause hier so ein 27 Zoll Display und wenn ich, das ist eigentlich auf meinem Scha-
Du alter Poser.
Naja, das ist nix mehr gepostet. Ich war letztens bei CyberPoll und hab mir diese Fernsehe angeguckt mit Senior Poser. 65 Zoll, also 27 Zoll ist ja gar nix mehr eigentlich. Da fängt man ja unten an. Egal, jedenfalls steht das normalerweise auf meinem Schreibtisch und wenn ich halt einen Film gucke, dann stelle ich das so mitten in den Raum und setz mich auf meinen Sofa und hab das dann so vor meiner Nase und stelle dann gerne, wenn ich dann doch ein bisschen surfen will, stelle ich mein Display auf Retina um, obwohl das eigentlich kein Retina-Display ist. Das ist dann so, dass aus den zweieinhalbtausend Punkten, also es wird einfach alles doppelt so groß, ich kann prima dann brausen, ohne dass ich das nicht mehr sehen kann, weil ich ja so ein bisschen weiter wegsetze. So, und was dann aber, ja, dann, okay, dann kennst du das ja schon mal, was dann halt aber nicht passiert ist, wenn du dann dir die Feinden am Icon anguckst, dann sehen die alle scheiße aus. Und wenn du dann so, zum Beispiel du hast so ein Bild auf dem Desktop, das sieht scheiße aus. Wenn du das aber verdoppelst, Apple D, so ganz simpel, dann machst du ja eine Kopie von dem Bild. Und bei dem Bild sieht das, das Preview von dem Icon sieht dann voll super aus. Das heißt, wenn du in dem Retina-Modus bist, dann erstellt er die Icons auch in doppelter Auflösung. So, dann dachte ich mir, alles klar. Das heißt, ich hab früher mal, anscheinend hat Apple das irgendwann gewechselt und man muss jetzt einmal seine Thumbnails, irgendwie so heißen die, muss man einmal irgendwie killen und die neu machen. Hab ich ein bisschen gegoogelt, da gibt es auch was. Ich kann ja mal hier so einen Link irgendwie reinschmeißen. Ich hab jetzt eigentlich damals einen anderen gefunden, aber der hier sollte auch tun. Und hab sozusagen diese Datenbank gelöscht. Das wird nämlich von einem Quick Look Demon, wird dieser Job erledigt und wird in, wo ist das hier, in Private-WAR-Folders und blub blub blub mehrere Unterordner, wird das halt in so einer SQLite-Datenbank gespeichert, sodass das halt nicht immer parallel zu den Bildern irgendwie im Fein da rumliegt, sondern das alles schön in einer DB. Dann war ich ganz frech, hab die zur Seite geschoben, hab den Ordner sozusagen leer gemacht, dass der Quick Look Demon nichts mehr findet, sodass der frisch von vorne anfängt und drrt, siehe da, sofort wurden von dem Quick Look Demon, der hat seine DB nicht mehr gefunden, hat ja einfach mal ganz schnell alle Eignisse neu gemacht und dann waren die alle schön in High Quality und ich dachte, mein Problem wäre gelöst und alles sieht jetzt schick aus. Ja, Pustekuchen. Ich habe mich dann irgendwie, ich lege meinen Rechnern immer schlafen, komme am nächsten Tag wieder, logge mich wieder ein, habe nicht den Retina-Modus weggemacht, ja der war immer noch an, seit dem Schlafenlegen und so weiter, oder vielleicht habe ich auch neu gebootet, ich weiß nicht mehr so genau. Jedenfalls, was macht dieser scheiß Quick Look Demon, macht schon wieder alle Eignisse in der schlechten Qualität. Das heißt, es hat alles nichts gebracht, und das war schon die Geschichte. Also wenn jetzt jemand weiß, woran das liegt, dass der, obwohl ich eigentlich immer noch in diesem Pseudo-Retina-Modus bin und der trotzdem wieder die Eignis in einer alten Auflösung macht, oder warum Apple das jetzt nicht irgendwann sowieso schon vor ein paar Jahren einfach mal verdoppelt hat, weil halt manche Rechner Retina-Modus haben und manchmal nicht. Es kommt ja auch drauf an, du kannst ja auch, dein Laptop hat vielleicht Retina, hast aber auch ein Display, was nicht Retina ist, und dann müsste der ja mal hin und her schalten. Dann hätte ich ja von Apple gedacht, sie machen jetzt default die doppelte Auflösung, damit es einfach immer schick aussieht, ab irgendwann. Haben sie aber irgendwie nicht getan. Und entweder ist das ein Bug oder jemand kennt da noch eine Lösung oder man muss da irgendwo in diese SQLite-Datum, vielleicht ein Häkchen setzen und der merkt sich das dann oder so. Aber es ist wirklich optisch ein Unterschied, ob deine Bilder irgendwie so ein altes oder Retina-Modus-Icon, Thumbnail-Dings haben, weil es sieht schon doch deutlich anders aus. Nee, macht da irgendwie nicht. Da hätte ich auch gedacht. Also das wäre ja auch schön gewesen, dass du in einem Retina-Modus bleibst und der merkt alles klar, Eigenes älter als ein Tag, ich mach das jetzt mal neu und dann macht das in dem aktuellen Auflösungen neu, aber so haben sie es irgendwie auch nicht gemacht. Wobei ich ja grundsätzlich die Idee, die Bildchen hier in so einer SQLite-Datenbank zu speichern und vielleicht sogar mit so einer Art Time to Live oder so, dass er die auf jeden Fall alle einmal die Woche, einmal im Tag, irgendwann irgendwie wieder neu macht und so. Das ist ja alles eigentlich ein cooles Konzept.
Bilder in SQLite-Datenbanken zu speichern, findest du ein cooles Konzept?
Nennen wir mal was besseres. Willst du dir irgendwo ein Filesystem verstreuen, Tausende von Files? Das hältst du auch nicht. Du willst sie schon eigentlich gesammelt an einer Stelle haben.
Aber eine SQLite-Datenbank, also...
Na, was hast du denn noch für Ideen, alles als Einzelfile?
Also Blobs in Datenbanken speichern war irgendwie noch nie cool, oder?
Kommt auf die Datenbank an.
Wenn es entweder in den RAM passt, oder du eine ordentliche...
Na ja, RAM ist ja eben nicht, weil das soll ja wahrscheinlich auch bootübergreifend irgendwie nicht gemerkt werden.
Wollte ja auch gerade noch sagen. Also, entweder deine Datenbank, also das Dataset, wenn die läuft, ist im RAM und dann schnell, oder dein Filesystem oder dein Speichermikro, wo es herkommt, ist schnell. Dann ist es halt eigentlich der DB ziemlich wurscht, wie viel da im Dataset drin ist. Also, für die Indices und die Query-Performance macht das nichts, ob da viel Blobs drin sind, es sei denn halt, deine Disk ist langsam und das passt nicht in den RAM.
Ich hab mir jetzt auch die Table von der Datenbank auch noch nicht angeschaut, was da alles so für Fälle damit drin hat, aber ich find das erst mal nicht so schön.
Naja, und gerade so ein Cache, wo du ja öfter mir wieder Sachen wegmachst, da musst du ein Vacuum drauf machen, was ähnlich lang dauert.
Ich würde behaupten, der Quick Look Demon kriegt natürlich von dem Files-Events-Demon bestimmt so eine Art Notification, wenn Files geändert werden oder gelöscht werden und dann haut er das wahrscheinlich sofort und automatisch raus. Also so stelle ich mir das immer vor. Ich hab schon oft gemerkt, dass manchmal nicht alle das so machen, wie ich mir das vorstelle, sowohl im Guten als auch im Negativen. Aber ja, jedenfalls hier dachte ich, alles wäre schick, aber dann war es dann doch nicht so einfach, wie ich mir dachte. Aber wer mal halt seine Eigenschaften irgendwie löschen will oder sich das mal angucken will, dann in diesem Link, den ich gepostet habe, da kann man ungefähr sehen, wo die sind oder nach welchem Namen man suchen muss. Oder wer mal in diese Eskoleitdaten reingucken will, vielleicht sind ja da doch noch irgendwelche Flex dran.
Ich hab ja mit meiner Band, die sich jetzt neu formiert hat, letztens mal wieder so einen Song im Proberaum aufgenommen. Und dann muss man ja das so ein bisschen noch bearbeiten, damit es für den Konsum geschulten Hörer auch nach was klingt. Und da braucht man ja hier und da so ein paar Plugins, oder mehr als nur ein Audiospuren-Schnitt-Tool und ein paar Fader. Da kommt ja üblicherweise ein Kompressor, ein Equalizer zum Einsatz, mindestens vielleicht auch noch ein Limiter. Und wer sich mit Audio schon beschäftigt hat, da gibt es halt so Plug-In-Schmieden und ganz oft sehen diese Audio-Plugins auch aus, wie früher die alten Analoggeräte. Und ich fand das schon immer so ähnlich, wie das Kettensymbol zum Speichern, irgendwie so ein Anachronismus oder so. Also irgendwie ist mir das nie in den Kopf gekommen, warum die so mit fixierter Auflösung so ein Bild da dir präsentieren von einem Kompressor von 19er schlagen mich tot, mit den Knöpfen, wo du mit der Maus den Drehknopf drehst und dann irgendwo so, das war alles immer so ein Frickelscheiß und ich hab das nie wirklich gemocht. Und dann hab ich mal durch Zufall, ne eigentlich nicht durch Zufall, ich hab nach nem guten Kompressor, nach nem guten Equalizer gesucht und dann, was man halt so als Nerd so macht, dann guckt man halt verschiedene Review-Seiten durch und irgendwie so findet man dann welche. Und dann hab ich eine Firma gefunden, ich glaub die sitzen in Holland und die machen Plug-Ins total großartig fürs 21. Jahrhundert, weil, nämlich Punkt Nummer eins, sie akzeptieren den Fakt, dass du an einem Computer sitzt, dass du fucking große Displays hast und dass es überhaupt keinen Sinn macht, irgendwie jetzt ein analoges Metallblech dir darzustellen mit Drehknöpfen, die man mit der Maus schubsen muss, sondern sie nehmen einfach alles, was man am Computer machen kann und bauen einfach Plug-Ins, die von vorne bis hinten einfach so richtig, so muss Software sein, dir als Eindruck vermitteln.
Also weg mit dem Geomorphen-Wahnsinn.
Ja, genau, sondern irgendwie, hey Computer, 21. Jahrhundert, hochauflösende Displays, Rechenpower, um dir die Fourier-transformierten Kurven anzuzeigen und so weiter. Und der Equalizer von denen, der Kompressor von denen, der Multibandkompressor von denen und der Limiter, das sind absolute Top-Notch-Spitzenprodukte. Also du siehst auch, jetzt wo ich die kenne, tatsächlich fällt mir auch immer mehr auf, dass Leute in ihren Tutorial-Videos hier und da mal so diese Fabfilter-Plugins sozusagen featuren. Und ich kann nur jedem empfehlen, der mal ein ordentliches Plugin haben will, einen EQ, einen Kompressor, einen Limiter, checkt die mal aus, da gibt es irgendwie, ich glaube, 30 Tage Trial-Versionen. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass die meisten Leute, wenn sie die Trial-Versionen ausprobiert haben und danach sozusagen, die immer noch brauchen, dass die dann auch kaufen. Du kannst, wenn du da bei Shop mal klickst, oben im Menü, das Schöne bei denen ist, also die Plug-Ins sind einzeln, die sind nicht super günstig, aber sind auch nicht super teuer. Und das Schöne ist, sie haben Bundles, wo du richtig viel Geld sparst, aber du willst vielleicht wirklich erstmal den Limiter haben, zum Beispiel. Wenn du dich dann später entscheidest, ok, jetzt will ich noch den Kompressor dazu, kriegst du einen Discount. Wenn du am Ende alle Plug-Ins einzeln kaufst, kommst du auf den gleichen Preis wie das Bundle. Sozusagen, je mehr Plug-Ins du kaufst, desto günstiger wird's am Ende, sodass du am Ende bei diesem Bundle-Preis landest. Das finde ich halt schon mal sehr charmant und sie haben auch gleich eingebaut, wenn ich dir jetzt einen Link schicke zu dem Shop, dann kriegst du zum Beispiel 10% Rabatt und ich krieg irgendwie 10 Euro für das nächste Plug-In irgendwie gut geschrieben. Also, alles total schön und gut gemacht und wirklich die Plug-Ins sind vom allerfeinsten. Kann ich wirklich nur...
Was ist denn da? Ist da was für Podcasts dabei oder ist das alles nur wieder Musiker-Bedarf?
Naja, ich meine du hast ja den Kompressor quasi hinter dem Pre-Amp direkt vom Konverter, oder?
Also derzeit in diesem Setup ist mein Kompressor noch Hardware und steht da unten und ich hab das nicht in der Software drin, was halt zu tun hat, dass ich hier noch keinen Setup habe mit Hinterbandkontrolle. Wir hören nicht das, was gerade im Reaper aufgenommen wird, auch wenn das, sagen wir mal, so die nächste, wie sagt man so schön, die nächste Evolutionsstufe wäre, die nächste Angst. Ja, habe ich auch schon lange Angst vor, deswegen gibt es das hier auch noch nicht.
Aber ich sag mal so, diese Plug-Ins sind schon eher Post-Processing und nicht Live-Processing, also insofern... Na ja, weiß nicht Roddy, du kennst dich ja da ein bisschen mehr aus, aber würde das für eine Live-Recording-Situation Sinn machen, Plug-In sozusagen? Geht das überhaupt, dass du das...
Na ja, jedes Plug-In macht halt Delay, ne? Also, je nachdem was es tut natürlich, aber gerade so Kompression und so ein Zeug, wenn du da Look-Ahead machen kannst und dann da drauf rumrechnen... Also, entweder du hast ein großes Delay, dann kannst du natürlich Look-Ahead machen. Oder aber du hast kein großes Delay, dann kannst du kein Look-Ahead machen. Also, wie du es drehst und wendest, ist...
Ist eher für Post-Processing, würde ich sagen.
Ja, wenn sie leistungsfähig sind, klar. Also, ansonsten kannst du auch Hardware nehmen. Also, so gut wie Hardware sollte es aber eigentlich sein.
Das Ding ist ja für Live-Situationen zum Beispiel auch, theoretisch bei Musik-Recordern macht es schon Sinn, einen nicht zu krass eingestellten Kompressor schon direkt hinter dem Preamp zu haben, damit du halt ein relativ homogenes Signal kriegst und vor allen Dingen keine Clippings oder Spitzen.
Das ist das, was ich hier fahre eigentlich.
Genau, und dann im Post-Processing setzt du dir einen Limiter oder einen Kompressor oder einen Equalizer auch nochmal viel gestaltender ein, während du nach dem Preamp Equalizer und Kompressen nur so ein bisschen das Signal vormassierst, damit es schon einigermaßen richtig ankommt. Aber das ist wirklich, würde ich eher sagen, für die Nachbearbeitung. Ich hatte erst den Limiter gekauft, weil mich haben auch diese ganzen Limiter genervt, so ein bisschen von ihrem Interface und wie sie sich verhalten und wie sie klingen. Und der ist zum Beispiel auch richtig gut. Den kannst du so voll an die Wand fahren.
Die heißen ja auch Limiter. Und du hörst echt sehr spät erst, dass der wirklich da so knallhart quasi die Spitzen wegschneidet. Der macht ja ein bisschen mehr, sonst würde es ja scheiße klingen. Aber der hat mich schon mal echt begeistert, weil du kannst wirklich sehr weit das Ding hochfahren, bevor du wirklich hörst, dass es verzerrt oder distorted. Und die haben auch so ein paar Plugins-Videos, zum Beispiel der Multiband-Kompressor. Wenn du dir das Video einfach von diesem Interface anmachst, ist es so, so muss Software. Ich glaube, das ist der genau. About this Plugin, klick mal da neben dem Buy Now-Button. Die haben da, Watch Demo, genau, da links gibt es diesen Button. Also einfach wie so dieses ganze Interface funktioniert. Du kannst für jedes Band auch so einen Solo-Button machen. Dann hörst du nur, was in diesem Band passiert, dass du auch die richtige Frequenz erwischst. Und das ganze Interface ist so super responsiv und fluffig. Und du siehst halt live irgendwie, wo die Kompression auch wirklich anschlägt. Das ist einfach nur schön.
Vor allem sowas, finde ich, trägt auch enorm dazu bei, dass man überhaupt mal versteht, was da eigentlich passiert.
Genau.
Das ist halt auch so mit diesen Standard-Controls und Parametern, die man da hat. Wenn man nicht extrem genau weiß, was man da eigentlich gerade einsetzt, dann ist das irgendwie schon schwierig, aber sowas auch noch so elegant zu visualisieren. Insbesondere, welchen Effekt hat mein Setting jetzt konkret? Wo kickt es irgendwie ein? Das ist halt extrem wertvoll.
Leider ruckelt oder lädt jetzt das Video nicht ordentlich.
Was erlauben, YouTube?
Screenen wie eine Flasche leer. Und auf jeden Fall auch der Single-Kompressor. Genau, das ist nämlich auch so ein Teil. Kompression ist auch immer wirklich ein Thema, wo gerade so Audio-Anfänge erstmal so ein bisschen ins Straucheln geraten, was jetzt eigentlich die einzelnen Parameter bedeuten. Und auch bei diesem Kompressor von denen sieht man das wirklich, also nicht bei den Multiband, sondern auch bei diesem einfachen, extrem schön. Zu dem Thema kann ich übrigens auch empfehlen, der Typ, der diesen Podcast Recording Lounge macht, den wir hier auch schon mal irgendwann gefeaturet haben, der macht jetzt einen YouTube-Kanal und hat jetzt auch so ein paar Videos zum Thema Kompression herausgebracht, wo er erklärt, wie welcher Parameter eigentlich greift und klärt auch so ein paar Mythen auf, so wann quasi die Attack und der Release eigentlich wirkt und so weiter. Sucht mal auf YouTube einfach nach Recording Lounge, da werdet ihr diese Videos bestimmt schnell finden.
Na, du guckst dir jetzt mal gleich nochmal nach.
Zum Thema Kompressor noch eine Geschichte aus dem Nähkästchen. Ableton hatte ja bei der allerersten Live-Version hatten sie auch einen Kompressor drin und mussten sich dann aber hinterher eingestehen, dass dieser Kompressor irgendwie nicht so arbeitet, wie er sein soll. Und deswegen gab es gleich zur zweiten Version einen neuen Kompressor, der dann das tat, was ein Kompressor tun sollte. Aber sie mussten den ersten natürlich drin lassen, weil die Leute natürlich auch Songs gemacht haben mit dem ersten Kompressor. Und wenn du dann den Kompressor einfach weglässt, dann kannst du ja den Song nicht mehr anhören.
Ja, das natürlich auch bitter, ja. Genau, und dann jetzt hier noch, ich pack noch schnell die Links zu diesen Plugins und so weiter in den Chat, den YouTube-Channel auch. Und jetzt noch abschließend zu diesem ganzen Thema, wer sich nämlich auch so ein bisschen mit so Audio mixen und mastern und keine Ahnung was beschäftigen will. Ein Thema ist halt auch Equalizer. Das ist halt auch ein Thema, was irgendwie da nie weggeht und womit man sich mal irgendwie beschäftigen muss. Und wenn man keine Ahnung hat, dann stellt man halt da wild an diesen Frequenzen rum und denkt so, ja so müsste es passen. Und hat eigentlich verschlimmbessert im Wesentlichen. Und dann habe ich auch, ich glaube über diese Recording-Launch-Podcast habe ich ein Tool entdeckt und das heißt Train Your Ears EQ Edition. Und was das macht ist, du kannst halt deine Songs da reinladen und kannst bestimmte Sachen trainieren. Zum Beispiel Frequenzbänder raushören. Und dann spielt er sozusagen dein Song aus deiner Library und bietet dir sozusagen drei oder fünf Optionen an, welches Frequenzband ist jetzt geboostet. Und dann durch so ein schönes Lernschema und Wiederholschema kannst du sozusagen dein Ohr ein bisschen schulen und relativ schnell kommen an einen Punkt, wo man in diesem Spiel quasi schon relativ gut so eingrenzt kann, das muss so irgendwie bei, weiß nicht, so vielleicht 200 bis 500 Hertz sein oder, ne? Und ich glaube, das Tool gibt's gerade auch relativ gut vergünstigt und ich hab das jetzt schon ein Weilchen immer mal ausprobiert und immer mal so zehn Minuten mitgespielt und es ist echt erstaunlich, wie schnell man da so plötzlich weiß, ah, hier, das ist irgendwie vier Kilohertz oder, ne? Also wer irgendwie Interesse daran hat, kann das sich mal reinfahren, ist echt ganz hilfreich, um mal dem Thema EQ und was eigentlich so Frequenz boosten oder runternehmen und so weiter bedeutet, sich da gut antrainieren. Und ich finde halt so die Idee auch super umgesetzt. Wenn ihr euch das Demovideo da mal auf der Seite anguckt, dann kriegt ihr auch relativ schnell mit, wie das dann so abläuft. Und es ist halt auch zum Beispiel einer meiner Lieblings-Audio-Engineers, der Bob Katz, der ist auch so einer der großen Audio-Mastering-Korifäen, der hat das hier zum Beispiel auch gleich hier gefeaturet und meint, der Leute, guckt euch das mal an, wenn er das ernst meint. Genau. Ist auf jeden Fall auch ganz schnuffig gemacht. So, das sind meine Audio-Tipps, glaube ich.
Was kannst du dir aus diesem Scheiß-Netz alles für geile Sachen rausziehen?
Ah, ja und da gibt es...
Glaublich.
Und dann also für geile Sachen aus dem Netz ziehen, es gibt ja die Webseite, die habe ich auch bestimmt schon mal erwähnt, groov3.com, wo es zu jeder Audio-Software und zu jedem möglichen Aspekt von Audiobearbeitung einfach unfassbar gute Tutorials gibt, die sind bezahlt, also die kosten nicht viel, aber kosten halt Geld, aber die sind dann dementsprechend auch wirklich hochwertiger Content und da gibt es tatsächlich auch zum Beispiel für Reaper, also auch so für so Nischen- oder Randsoftware, die jetzt nicht so im Mainstream sind, so wie Pro Tools oder Logic, gibt es auch halt richtig gute Tutorials von Top-Leuten, die dir dann mal erklären, wie man in der bestimmten Software halt...
Wollt ihr auf derselben Webseite?
Nee, das ist groove3.com, also die ist halt auch so für Edutainment, ich glaube so hieß die, echt eine super coole Adresse, da habe ich auch schon einiges gelernt, ich packe mal ein Chat hier auch wieder. Da gibt es auch Tutorials für Reaper. Du musst mal da oben, geh mal hoch ins Main Menu, Browse wahrscheinlich, View, Products, und da gibt es hier links die Liste von allen möglichen Sachen, zu denen sie irgendwas haben, und da gibt es auch Reaper. Und da gibt es dann Reaper 4 Explained, und dann zeigen sie einem halt mal so alles, was da so in diesem Reaper eigentlich geht. Und ich meine, Reaper 5 ist jetzt zwar draußen, aber da sind immer noch viele Sachen aktuell. Und auch dieses Reaper-Tipps und Tricks war zum Beispiel auch ein kleiner Augenöffner in der Hinsicht, weil die klicken dann halt mal Sachen an, die man aufgrund der nicht so übersichtlich gestalteten Einstellungen vielleicht auch nicht anklickt. Und dann stellt man plötzlich fest, oh Moment, da geht ja noch ein bisschen mehr, als ich man dachte. Ja, jetzt ist aber Schluss mit Audio-Tipps für heute.
Bist du gut? Gute Tipps. Jetzt müssen wir nur mal die Zeit haben, das auch alles irgendwie sich rein zu pfeifen. Ja, kann man ja mal sagen. Hab am 22. November 2000... Das ist also jetzt 10 Jahre her.
Und geht die URL noch?
Was geht noch?
Geht die URL noch auf den ersten Podcast, auf den ersten veröffentlichten?
Äh, unter der ursprünglichen URL sollte eigentlich, kann ich mal ausprobieren.
Wie war dieses Motto Good URLs never change oder wie war das? Ich wollte dich jetzt nicht total aus dem Thema reißen, aber cool.
Geht noch.
Bravo, alles richtig gemacht. Good Web Citizen Award.
Ja, mit redirect und pipapo. Wer das noch nicht gehört hat, CAE 001, da werdet ihr euch an den Kopf fassen. Weil das war halt irgendwie alles lame, da hab ich halt monologisch was ins Mikrofon reingetan. Das war nicht mehr als eine vage Ankündigung von ich mach jetzt da mal was. Weil es muss ja mal was getan werden, sonst macht's ja wieder keiner. Ja, und da hat sich ja dann doch so einiges draus ergeben. Wer hätte es gedacht, ne? Also, ich hab das auch in einem längeren Blogpost.
Hast du auch sehr schön geschrieben.
Hast du gelesen, ja? Ja, das sind so diese Momente, wo man...
Nostalgisch wird?
Ja, nostalgisch und vor allem, das ist auch immer so dieses... Ich kann sowas auch immer nur einen Tag vorher, nachts, wenn ich eigentlich ins Bett müsste, aber trotzdem irgendwie das Hirn nicht abschalten kann. Das ist so der Moment, wo man sowas schreibt. Also, ich hab das irgendwie gar nicht von langer Hand geplant, sondern ich saß hier so und dachte mir so, jetzt schreib ich mal was. Und dann so, brrrr, hab ich das Ding so mehr oder weniger in einem Blog einfach so runtergeschrieben. Ja, und das ist so ein bisschen so meine persönliche Sichtweise der Dinge und wie ich das alles so erlebt habe und was ich mir auch so denke nach 10 Jahren. Was ja eine ganze Menge Zeit ist. Normalerweise nach 10 Jahren eigentlich immer so das Handtuch schmeißen und irgendwie meinen Job wechseln.
10 Jahre ist schon ziemlich lange dafür.
Ja, schon ganz schön gut. Ich komm nicht mal auf zwei. Wie? Na, wenn ich so meine Jobs so angucke, ist es alle mal 14 Monate.
Ich habe das Gefühl, du machst ja eigentlich immer das Gleiche.
Ja, aber immer woanders.
Ja gut, aber du bist immer im selben Business.
Ach so, du wechselst alle 10 Jahre komplett das Business, meinst du?
Ja, ich hab 10 Jahre irgendwie programmiert und administriert. Dann hab ich irgendwie 10 Jahre Events organisiert. Ich hab das hier alles immer auch irgendwie nebenbei noch so ein bisschen gemacht, aber so im Zentrum meiner Aktivität stand halt irgendwie das. Und dann hab ich...
Weißt du, du willst jetzt aufhören?
Nee, komischerweise nicht. Also wahrscheinlich bin ich jetzt auch viel zu alt, um nochmal einen Change zu machen. Nee, eigentlich nicht. Aber es ist nur so, mich reizt das jetzt halt. Also einerseits finde ich, ist hier noch genug Musik drin. Also hier kann man irgendwie noch eine Menge erfinden und machen und tun. Da ist einfach noch eine Menge Luft. Und das macht ja auch irgendwie immer noch Spaß. Das andere hat mich dann nach zehn Jahren auch genervt. Das war dann irgendwie auch gut. Ich hatte natürlich keinen Bock mehr auf diese Programmierung. Also ich fand das Programmieren an sich geil.
Du warst ja auch nie dein eigener Chef, oder?
Ja, hätte ich natürlich sein können. Ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich so der Vorteil von der ganzen Programmiererei. Wenn du es drauf anlegst, wenn es jetzt wirklich dein Ding ist, dann kannst du ja selber losziehen und hackst ja einfach die Welt, wie sie dir gefällt. Und das wäre auch sicherlich eine Option gewesen, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat sich das einfach... Wie soll ich sagen? Das stand für mich damals auch so ein bisschen für so eine verlorene Jugend, die dann an anderen Stellen nochmal ausgebessert werden musste. Und dazu war also einfach ein Shift nötig. Ich meine, seit ich 14, 15 bin, glaube ich, so habe ich mich eigentlich im Wesentlichen nur noch so in Nerdkreisen bewegt. Egal ob das jetzt so ein Schachklub war oder halt so die anderen Kids, die bei Kaufhof alle in der Computerabteilung rumstanden. Weil, naja, der einzige Ort, wo es halt Computer gab damals. Das war sozusagen das Äquivalent zum Internet. Da konnte man hingehen und hatte auf alles Zugriff. Es war halt nicht so viel, aber das war sozusagen die maximale Verfügbarkeit von Ressourcen in puncto Gerät, Information, Daten, Software und so weiter. Das fand halt irgendwie da statt. Ja, und ich musste das einfach mit anderen Dingen und Erlebnissen einfach mal erfüllen, das Leben. Und da passt einfach diese Programmiertätigkeit für mich nicht so richtig rein, weil ich finde, das ist halt auch schon so eine Sache, da musst du echt dabei bleiben. Da musst du wirklich dich auch reinfuchsen. Und die richtig guten Programmierer sind halt die, die es auch eigentlich nie so richtig gelassen haben. Die eigentlich immer irgendeine Codebase am Schieben waren. Irgendwie dann nochmal eine neue Programmiersprache oder auch den ganzen Bestand an Standard-Apps einfach nochmal neu schreiben in dem aktuellen Scheiß und ein neues Betriebssystem und darauf nochmal portieren. Also da ist immer was in Bewegung, da lebt irgendwie was. Und ich bin irgendwie so relativ früh, da habe ich mich schon mal in einer Archive, in der ich mal auch damit zu tun habe, dass ich halt eine Zeit lang auch für andere was gemacht habe und in dem Sinne nicht meine Codebase aufgebaut habe. Na ja, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall kam es dann halt so.
Wie auch immer, so.
Eine Sache noch in dem Zusammenhang, da gibt es jetzt einen Link auf META-Ebene.me, auf diesen Text und da prangt übrigens auch noch ein Podcast-Abo-Button, den ich da leider erst jüngst hinzugefügt habe. Ich habe halt auch noch so einen kleinen Podcast-Kanal aufgemacht für die META-Ebene als solche. Das habe ich hier, glaube ich, noch nie so erwähnt. Das ist halt so ein Low-Volume-Kanal, wo ich einfach, na ja, sozusagen über die META-Ebene der META-Ebene berichte. Das heißt, wenn es neue Releases gibt, neue Podcasts, Projekte, wenn sich irgendwas generelles ändert oder erwähnenswert ist, dann haue ich das irgendwie da rein. Das sind nur so Ankündigungen, aber wer sozusagen primär eigentlich über Audio in Sync bleiben möchte und auch über neue Projekte informiert werden will, der kriegt das halt da. Hier gibt es keine Sammelfizien, hier gibt es Informationspodcasts.
Aber man kann sozusagen sagen, also solange der, also wenn der letzte Podcast knisterfrei ist, ja.
Dann werdet ihr merken, dass euch der ganze Scheiß auch nicht weitergehalten hat.
Dann kann es halt sein, ich versuche noch andere zu finden, so drei wären gut.
Wenn der letzte Podcast knisterfrei ist, wenn der letzte Chaptermark eingebaut ist.
Und auch der letzte iPhone Podcast klein, alle Metadaten unterstützt, dann wird es Tim auch langweilig und dann sucht er sich die nächste Beschäftigung.
Ja, mir gehen da sicherlich auch die Betätigungsfelderideen nicht aus. So, wollen wir jetzt Schluss machen?
Hätten wir das auch geklärt.
Was ist denn eigentlich, sind wir irgendwie?
Ich hab keinen Bingo.
Heute machen wir nicht so lang, oder?
Ich hab auch kein Bingo. Viel grün, aber kein Bingo.
Frage an den Chat, an den Bingo-Admin. Vom Bingo OS. Haben wir denn einen Gewinner? Gibt es denn irgendwie, hat sich das Bingo-Spiel während dieser Sendung in irgendeiner Form so abgespielt, dass man sagen kann, hier gibt es jemanden, der nach den Regeln der Zunft gewaltet hat und genug Belege eingetütet hat? Ich lese ein Ja. Die Frage ist, wer?
Der kennt jetzt eine Küchenwaage. Bevor wir diese Frage klären, es dauert noch ein paar Sekunden, aber wir müssen uns auf jeden Fall nochmal ausführlich bei allen Lebkuchenspenden bedanken, würde ich sagen. Es war wirklich eine überwältigende Menge. Es war auch ein Paket Schokolade dabei. Ich würde fast sagen, es sieht aus, mindestens mit Füller, Füllfederhalter, wie es richtig heißt. Ein Brief.
Das ist schon fast kaligraphisch.
Kaligraphisch, also wirklich super, vielen Dank.
Ob das mit dem Apple Pencil gemacht ist?
Sicher nicht.
Sehr schön geschrieben, aber mich bitte nicht mit Y schreiben.
Das stimmt, Foddy schreibt sie mit I. Aber das... So, la la la... Gott, das ist zu viel Schokolade. Das macht uns alles nur dick. Das ist Haselnuss, die nehme ich nicht.
Gib mir mal, halt halt halt, die will ich.
Dennis, möge bitte aufpassen, dass er kein Stück von der Haselnussschokolade erwischt.
Wie kommt er auf die Idee? Hab ich mal gesagt, ich mag keine Haselnuss?
Magst du keine Haselnuss?
Weiß nicht.
Hast du wahrscheinlich gesagt.
Schon. Weißt nicht, ob du keine Haselnuss magst? Ich dachte jetzt, er meint, dass ich keine vertrage.
Das glaube ich jetzt nicht.
Also Essen kann ich dich schon mögen. Die kann man schon essen. Aber Mandeln ist besser, deswegen habe ich mir die gegriffen.
Vielen Dank an Daniel. Vielen Dank auch an alle anderen. Ich habe mir jetzt die Namen nicht aufschreiben können.
Das liegt auch daran. Und auch Dank an den Einhörer, der mir diese wirklich praktischen Grünen-Einohm-Widerstände geschickt hat. Die waren auch wirklich gut.
Also da kann ich erstmal einiges mit löten. Grüne-Einohm-Widerstände?
Ja, ne, war natürlich ein Mega-Ohm. Und ich glaube, für die nächste Sendung müsst ihr jetzt erstmal keine Lebkuchen und Schokolade mehr einschicken.
Ich glaub auch.
Also jetzt wieder freuen wir uns über Sachspenden. Oder Flatterklicks. Bier, ihr fandet doch Bier gut.
Ich wollte ja Studentenfutter haben. Das ist ja nun nicht gekommen.
Also hört hin, Studentenfutter.
Nächstes Mal kommt hier so eine metrische Tonne.
Studentenfutter hat mehrere Vorteile. Das ist wirklich so, wenn du Hunger hast. Also gerade so hier im Studio, wo man nicht immer so weg kann.
Aber Nüsse machen auch fett, das ist ja auch klar.
Ich mag aber keine Rosinen.
Aber es ist halt nicht so Schoko.
Aber wenn du dich mit so ein Nüschen vollstummst, das ist schon sehr potent.
Das soll ja auch ernähren.
Also hört hin, le monsieur Prit Damour möchte gerne Studentenfutter haben.
Also ich würde ja auch einfach nur eine Nussmischung ohne Rosinen. Ich bin nämlich auch bei Rolli, ich mag keine Rosinen.
Ach, wenn man sich Rosinen hasse, daran wird die Welt noch zugrunde gehen.
An den Rosinenpickern.
Rosinen sind super.
Der Sieger, der vom Admin ausgerufen wurde, heißt Si2PO. Mir war jetzt gerade nicht so ganz klar, welche Achse hier. Ah, da haben wir eine dritte Reihe.
Skip, Skip, Skip hatten wir.
Nicht.
Tja, überführt. Bist du sicher?
Also ich bin mir sicher, dass ich keinen Skip, Skip, Skip von mir gegeben hab. Dennis vielleicht?
Heute nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Wir zweifeln das an, bis der Gegenbeweis erbracht ist. Alles Zweifelhafte muss angezweifelt werden.
Ja, Audio Schnipsel, or it didn't happen.
Ah ja, hier.
Bevor ich von der vorletzten Sendung begonnen habe, jetzt wird das hier allgemein beklagt.
Naja, wir wetten das nächste Sendung aus.
Ne, wir lassen uns einfach jetzt mal einen offiziellen Sieger zustellen und verschicken eine Küchenwagen.
Ob er will oder nicht oder sie.
Wir haben jetzt hier gerade sozusagen Bia, Steve, wir haben Steve erwähnt.
Du hast Steve erwähnt.
Also Opa erzählt vom Krieg haben wir nicht gesagt, aber wir haben vom Krieg erzählt.
Da hat jemand ganz doll von seinem Krieg erzählt.
Also ich würde mal sagen, das ist ein sehr geschöhnter Bingo-Sieg. Also wenn man es jetzt wörtlich nehmen würde, dann...
Siehst du mal, das ist nämlich genau das Ding. Man muss bei solchen thematischen Belegen auch in irgendeiner Form ein Gremium haben, was eben in dem Moment auch absegnet, ja, das hat auch stattgefunden.
Also Steve habe ich aber auch geklickt. Steve ist da, Opa habe ich nicht geklickt, das ist nämlich bei mir nicht dabei gewesen.
Also Opa erzählt vom Krieg, ist auf jeden Fall nicht wörtlich gefallen.
Aber Tim hat es ja gemacht.
Aber Tim war der Opa.
Ich bin doch nicht Opa.
Aber das gibt, gibt, gibt, das zweifle ich auf jeden Fall an. Und ich lasse mich natürlich gerne eines Besseren belehren.
Ja, Meite hat den Chat gefragt, der Chat meinte, das passt schon so. Dann sagen wir auch, das passt einfach so. Gut, ich würde sagen, das war's. Mehr gibt's nicht, weil mehr können wir gerade nicht.
Ja, ist ja auch. Man muss ja nicht jedes Mal 5 Stunden machen.
Nö, haben wir letztes Mal schon gemacht. Also müssen wir mal...
Ohne D bitte.
E-Bend.
Heißt nicht E-Bend, sondern E-Ben.
Das macht man doch absichtlich. E-Bend.
E-Bend Agentur.
Gut, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei der Freak Show. In zwei Wochen sind wir wieder da. Und ja, dann sehen wir uns auch irgendwann auf dem Kongress. Ich hoffe, ihr kommt alle.